Na ja, wenn die anderen das nicht einsehen, dann fangen wir einfach schon mal an. Schönen guten Abend, hier ist Chaosradio Nummer 62. Danke schön, danke. Dufte, ihr seid Dufte. Chaosradio Nummer 62, ein alter Bekannter mit dem Mikrofon, und zwar Talunil. Hallo Talunil. Nebenbei sozusagen noch ein gewisser Sebastian, den ich selber gar nicht kenne. Hallo. Hallo. Und Crest Crest hat derzeit was besseres zu tun als am Mikrofon zu stehen, denn schließlich handelt es sich hierbei ja nur um eine Radiosendung.
Tja, man hat ja auch noch die verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe zu gucken, was mit dem Musikprogramm los ist, was ich halt in gutem Teil selbst ausgewählt habe. Und da stimmt noch ein bisschen was nicht, aber wird schon gefixt werden.
Ich kann dir sagen, was da nicht dran stimmt, das liegt auf Tims Festplatte.
Da sind so ein paar mp3s verloren gegangen, die eigentlich abgespielt werden sollen.
Was denn? Ich dachte, du lässt dich nur von Frauen so begrüßen, dass du erinnerst, die ein Haar, Tim.
Hast du mal einen Eingang?
Ist eigentlich ein guter Spruch zum Anmachen. Apropos Anmachen, wir haben ja gerade die Sendung angemacht. Chaosradio 62, das Thema heute?
Ist die Demoszene. Wir haben zwei Gäste hier, habe ich schon gesagt. Wir reden heute über die Geschichte der Demoszene, wie sie entstand und wie sie aktuell aussieht.
Und vielleicht auch über die Zukunft ein bisschen.
Genau.
Dann machen wir das mal. Ich habe ein Lied mitgebracht, da bestehe ich darauf, dass wir das spielen. Es ist nicht elektronisch, sondern es ist eine Coverversion von Rammstein. Das ist nicht schlimm. Was? Ich bin nicht schlimm. Das ist ein ganz schönes Lied. Ich spiele es jetzt einfach. Dann melden wir uns dann tatsächlich mal.
Oh nein, das Baby ist aufgewachsen wieder.
Ja, das waren also The Drachmen und die Sonne. Ihr Chaosradio 62 auf Fritz und unser Thema ist die Demoszene. Das sind also praktisch die Leute, die dafür sorgen, dass Eckhard Wertebaum in Berlin das Versammlungsrecht einschränken will. Im Studio Talunil als alter Bekannter und dann noch zwei Gäste aus der Demoszene, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Sebastian und Crest. Seit wann gibt's das? Also sag mal mal, was ist die Demoszene? Also ihr lauft ja nicht mit Schildern rum und lasst das Demonstrationsrecht einschränken.
Ja, mit dem Demonstrieren auf der Straße hat das herzig wenig zu tun, eigentlich gar nichts, sondern es hat eben mit Computern zu tun. Die Demoszene kann man eigentlich auch fast in die Anfänge der Computerei zurückführen. Also C64, Atari, ST und so, da hat das Ganze eigentlich mal begonnen. Und der Ursprung war da eigentlich mal die Cracker-Szene. Also so Leute, die halt Programme gecrackt haben, Spiele zum Beispiel, um zu kopieren zu können oder andere Sachen. Und die haben dann so in kleinen Programmchen bekannt gegeben, dass sie eben dieses Organis gekrackt haben und daraus ist dann eben so langsam eine eigene Kunstform und eben die Demoszene entstanden.
Das heißt, wenn ich so in den 80ern auf meinem C64 ein Sample hatte, das sich so angehört hat, als würde es eigentlich gar nicht auf dem C64 laufen dürfen, dann wart ihr das. Möglich ist es ja.
Wobei ich für mich, also für meine Person kreist, halt sagen muss, dass ich halt mit der C64 Szene nichts zu tun habe, weil ich erst zur Demoszene dazugestoßen bin, als ist schon auf dem PC alt auch, einigermaßen schon seinen Boden gefunden hat.
Moment mal eben, Tim will aus dem Hintergrund was sagen. Tim, was ist denn? Ach so, ja Tim findet auch C64. Du wolltest auch mal im Radio sein.
Super, der C64 ist toll, ja.
Übrigens, Tim Hittler aus dem Hintergrund. Was ist das, was du da futterst?
Sieht nach einer Apfeltasche aus.
Okay, er ist also eine Apfeltasche. Wie genau muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Naja, nicht ganz so. Also ist es so, dass die Programmierer sich gesagt haben, ich will jetzt mal zeigen, was ich kann. Und dann haben sie entsprechend besonders coole Sachen programmiert, die besonders gut aussahen und technisch eigentlich unmöglich schienen zu der Zeit damals. Und da ist dann so eine Art Wettbewerb entstanden, auch dass Leute versucht haben, sich gegenseitig jemanden zu übertrumpfen, den anderen zu dissen und so, ein bisschen wie bei der Rapszene auch. Und es haben sich dann Crews gebildet mit Grafikern.
Das ist aber eventuell noch ein Leiter in was Dissen ist, das weiß vielleicht auch nicht jeder.
Ja, Disrespect, das wissen wir schonmal. Hip Hop ist ja in.
Ja.
Hip Hop ist cool.
Hallo Talunil, du bist auch wieder bei uns.
Hip Hop hört Talunil hört Hip Hop. Hip Hop hört vielleicht auch Talunil, aber vor allem hört Talunil Hip Hop. Ja, jedenfalls haben sich dann Crews zusammengefunden.
Talunil braucht Hip Hop nicht, aber Hip Hop braucht Talunil.
Genau. Und die Leute haben sich dann zu mehreren Leuten zusammengesetzt und diese Intros vor den gecrackten Spielen halt auch mal ohne gecrackte Spiele programmiert und geguckt, was kann man eigentlich aus der Kiste rausholen und das dann veröffentlicht. Und so ist das eigentlich entstanden. Und das hat sich dann auf andere Systeme mehr oder weniger fortgepflanzt und mit der Zeit wurden halt die Systeme immer besser und natürlich wurden dann auch die Möglichkeiten immer besser und die Demos auch immer besser. Und im Moment ist es so, dass sich fast alles auf dem PC abspielt, dass die Leute die aktuellen Möglichkeiten der Grafikkarten etwa genauso nutzen wie jetzt meinetwegen Spiele wie Quake oder Unreal. Da werden halt krasse 3D-Welten teilweise programmiert und das wird halt alles auch in Echtzeit berechnet und dargestellt. Also man hat nicht einen Film auf der Platte, sondern man hat eine kleine Datei, eine ausführbare Datei und die errechnet dann während der Laufzeit das Ganze, was da dargestellt wird.
Das spielt sich aber nicht nur grafisch ab, das ist auch eine Musiksache.
Ne, Demos sind eigentlich zur Zusammensetzung aus Code, also den Effekten, den man so sieht, Grafiken, die halt eingebettet sind und der Musik, die im Hintergrund läuft.
Die Musik, die im Hintergrund läuft.
Ja, gute Stichworte.
Ist übrigens von?
Ha, von mir, ja.
Ja, von dir und dir ist Sebastian. Wie heißt es?
Das ist K2 heißt der Track.
K2 heißt der Track und Wayfinder heißt das Projekt, was du sozusagen bildest. Ganz genau. Hör mal mal lauter rein. Es ist immer wieder dasselbe. Ich merke nicht, wenn die Platten ausgedrückt werden. Wir hören einfach jetzt die nächste davon. Chaosradio 62, die Demo-Coder-Szene ist unser Thema hier auf Fritz und wir hören gerade Musik aus der Szene und zwar von Wayfinder, nämlich Sebastian, einer unserer Gäste hier im Studio, hat das hier getrackt, geschrieben, gemacht, gesungen. Herzlichen schönen guten Abend wollte ich sagen. Sebastian ist einer unserer Gäste, Krest ist mit dabei und Talunil, hallo.
Und Tim ist auch dabei.
Ja, Tim ist auch dabei, aber der ist gerade die Mate holen. Kann er ja auch nicht im Hintergrund rumbrüllen, da müssen wir keine Rücksicht auf den nehmen. Das Demo-Szene, niemand ist ja mit Plakaten rumgerannt, das ist also jedenfalls nicht ursächlich. Haben wir geklärt, was ist eine Demo?
Also eine Demo ist erstmal einfach ein selbstablaufendes Programm, also keine Interaktion, man sitzt einfach eben davor, klingt erstmal langweilig, ach, einfach nur da sitzen und gucken und zuhören halt. Aber eben in dieser Demo, da laufen dann verschiedene Effekte ab, im Idealfall schön miteinander synchronisiert zur Musik, mit guten Übergängen, halt im Idealfall schöner Grafik, guten Design, das macht eigentlich so ein ideales Demo aus. Wo dann eigentlich auch die Atmosphäre drüber kommt, die da in dieser Demo vermittelt werden soll.
Gibt es da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Wettkämpfe?
Ja, durchaus. Jede Menge, jede Menge.
Ist das ein globaler, also ein ständiger globaler Online-Wettkampf?
Global, also dieses Global.
Das ist also mehr eine europäische Sache.
Landparty-mäßig irgendwie.
Ja, das ist schon so ähnlich.
Landparty ist es halt nicht im weitesten Sinne. Die Leute sind zwar auf diesen großen Partys natürlich vernetzt, das ist klar heutzutage, aber es sind keine Landpartys im Sinne dessen, dass man einfach nur Sachen austauschen tut. Oder Spiel. Spielen tut. Die bekannten Spieler, brauche ich jetzt nicht aufzuzählen, weiß jeder Gamer, aber darum gibt es halt nicht in der Demoszene. Und auf diesen Partys, da gibt es natürlich Wettbewerbe in den verschiedensten Kategorien, Grafik, Musik, Demo, Intro, da kann man dennoch innerhalb der Sendung weiter darauf eingehen.
Das sind die lustigen Ranterscheinungen.
Können wir uns darauf jetzt bitte mal kaprizieren, was ist das für ein Spiel?
Ja, es ist ein Contest, also im Sinne von Freestyle auf einer Party, wird man einfach irgendwelche Dinge so weit werfen halt eben, aber mit Festplatten.
Mit Festplatten? Also man macht das normalerweise...
Man macht das normalerweise natürlich mit kaputten Festplatten, davon gibt es auf jeder Party genug. Aber wenn man besonders dekadent sein will, dann nimmt man natürlich auch die, wo der Quellcode drauf ist. Und naja, ist halt so, wenn man das auf einer Wiese spielt, dann kann es doch sein, dass man die hinterher nicht wieder findet. Das ist dann hinterher für denjenigen, der den Rasen mädt, natürlich eine schöne Überraschung auf der einen Seite. Aber wenn man dann irgendwie wichtige Daten drauf hat, ist halt doch schlecht.
Ja, das ist...
Und ich darf dazu sagen, also dieses Festplatten-Weitlauf, das ist schon eigentlich auf sehr wenige Partys beschränkt, wo das tatsächlich praktiziert wird. Also ursprünglich angefangen hat es nur auf der kleinen Untergrundparty hier in Deutschland. Meines Erachtens, zumindest weiß ich, ob es beim Ausland vielleicht auch schon mal gemacht wurde, aber ursprünglich wurde es bei offizieller kleinen Untergrundparty, die auch in diesem Jahr wieder stattfindet. Schöne Grüße an Scump, Simon Kissell. Und da wurde es halt mal eingeführt und so die ein oder andere Party hat es dann halt abgekupfert und auch mal bei sich halt mit aufgenommen ins Programm.
Gibt es da Fotos von?
Ja, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Fotos von. Ich kann ja mal die Webseite sagen. Das ist uc4gw.untergrund.net Da gibt es Fotos zu bestaunen vom Festplattenweitwurf und da gibt es auch zu sehen Leute...
Was, uc4gw?
Ja, so hieß die Veranstaltung...
.Conference 4 ist halt die vierte gewesen und gw, das ist halt so ein Zusatz, bei der uc hat man immer noch so halt...
Gib zu, du bist in Wirklichkeit Amateurfunka.
Das hat die Spezialität von dieser Underground-Konferenz. Da gibt es ja nicht immer so lustige Zusätze hinten dran. Aber uc4 ist besagt in eigentlich, das ist eben die vierte Underground-Konferenz. Und in diesem Jahr ist uc5 die fünfte Underground-Konferenz.
Ich verstehe, mittlerweile hat jeder vergessen, wie dieser URL hieß.
uc4gw.untergrund.net untergrund.net.
Die Musik, die Crest mitgebracht hat hier im Chaosradio 62 auf... Was ist das genau?
Ja, das ist die Audiophonik-CD, die haben zwei Szener halt zusammengestellt, halt haben sie sich viel Mühe mitgegeben, ist eine sehr professionelle Qualität, wie ihr vielleicht schon hören könnt. Und da ist die Bezugsquelle im Internet www.imphobia.cine.org, also CIMITSC im Englischen halt.
Imphobia, also I-M-P-H-O-B-I-A.
Genau. Also nochmal www.imphobia.cine.org.
www.imphobia.cine.org, kann das mal einer mitschreiben, dann pack ich das irgendwie heute Abend nochmal bei Fritz auf die Homepage. Da kann man sich jetzt nochmal alles angucken, was wir so an links raushauen.
Ja, ich fäll's mir auf die Stirn tätowieren.
Du bist so süß zu mir.
Übrigens, ein kleines Teil der Playlist, also mit Sicherheit keine Vollständigkeit, weil halt Sebastian ja auch so einige Sachen hier mitgebracht hat, aber ein kleines Teil der Playlist könnt ihr auf meiner Homepage abrufen, das ist eher crest.untergrund.net und da seht ihr dann schon die News zu der Sendung, die ihr jetzt läuft und da ist dann auch eine Playlist in diesen News drinnen.
Ach, das ist doch mal was.
Kauf Fanta.
Entschuldige, willste warum?
Ja, weil Fanta gut schmeckt und viel Vitamin C drin ist und Zucker.
Wir dürfen aber in dieser Uhrzeit keine Werbung mehr machen, das ist hier öffentlich-rechtlicher Tonung.
Entschuldigung.
Das könnte man ja auch auf Afrikola hinweisen.
Ja, also das finde ich nicht schlecht, den guten Rausch.
Ja, guter Rausch, ja.
Sebastian, willst du das bitte nochmal sagen? Matthias, da hat doch die Jingle-Maschine uns gerade im Stich gelassen.
Na ja, vielleicht ist es in einer anderen Zeit nicht so.
Versuchen wir das doch nochmal. Da kann es aber laut sein.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht trocken bei 17 bis 14 Grad morgen, dann stark bewegend Regen, einige Gewitter von Westen her bis zur Oder und Neiße. Das ist also quasi, wenn man auf die Karte guckt, von links nach rechts, so über Brandenburg und Berlin weg. Maximaltemperaturen bei 26 Grad morgen. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkos.
Die Rufung von Sommelin Mark auf ein Konto der CDU, nahen Schweizer Neufolk Stiftung, ist offenbar aufgeklärt. Der ehemalige CDU-Finanzbedarbeiter Weihrauch soll das Geld an eine Mitarbeiter der Schweizer USB-Bank in bar übergeben haben, berichtet die Bild-Zeitung. Der Bankangestellte sei auch bereit, vor den Spenden-Untersuchungsausschüssen auszusagen. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat sich grundsätzlich für eine Beteiligung der Bundeswehr an einem NATO-Einsatz in Mazedonien ausgesprochen. Deutschland werde sich seinen internationalen Verpflichtungen nicht entziehen können. sagte er in einem Interview. Wegen der Ermordung eines Obdachlosen hat das Landgericht Schwerin zwei junge Männer zur lebenslanger Haft bzw. 6, 5 Jahren Jugendhaft verurteilt. Die Angeklagten hatten den 50-jährigen Mann im vergangenen Sommer in Wismar so schwer misshandelt, dass er wenig später starb. Mehrere hundert jährige Schüler sind heute für mehr Mut und Toleranz im Alltag auf die Straße gegangen. Kinder und Jugendliche von etwa 20 Schulen hatten sich zu einem Sternmarsch versammelt, der bis zum Brandenburger Tor führte. Frankreich hat heute die Wehrpflicht abgeschafft. Der Volk bei der Umwandlung der Streitkräfte in eine Berufsarmee habe diesen Schritt ein Jahr früher als geplant ermöglicht, erklärte Präsident Chirac. Die Armee verfüge über genügend Freiwillige.
Wir sind an Frankreich los. Kein Verkehr heute, Matthias? Nein. Das Leben kann hart sein. Danke schön. Es ist 22.31 Uhr. Danke, danke Crest. Crest hat die Platte mitgebracht. Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, wer zum Teufel ist Crest? Ich hab doch Fritz angemacht. Das ist das Chaos Radio hier. Das war Chaos Radio 62. Die Demo-Coder-Szene ist unser Thema heute Abend. Unsere Studio-Gäste, die also noch nicht oft hier waren bzw. noch gar nicht, sind Sebastian. Hallo und Crest. Ihr beide seid aus der Szene und codert und codert. Und Crest hat mich genötigt, bösen Blickes, von dieser Platte, die ich hier in der Hand halte, Sachen zu spielen. Und das war eben, was haben wir gehört, das war Adam Skorpik Skorupa aus Polen mit Cocoon. Sag nochmal, was das für eine Platte ist. Mir gefällt die Musik ausnehmend gut, die da drauf ist.
Ja, das ist halt eine Platte, die halt komplett halt von Szenen, von Szene-Musik enthält halt. Und die Musik ist eben von Szene-Musikern gemacht worden und ist halt sehr hohe Qualität. Und ja, wenn ihr auf der Fritz-Site jetzt mal die Cam euch anguckt, dann könnt ihr auch mal die Hülle von dieser CD so ein bisschen sehen.
Falls die Webcam funktioniert, die hat... Das ist ja verblüffend.
Ja, in der Playlist auf meiner Homepage, die ich ja schon mal kurz erwähnt habe, da sind die Titel, die von der Audiophonic CD gespielt werden, dann auch schon mit einem Audiophonic Zusatz versehen. Da steht dann in Klammern Audiophonic dazu, so dass er dann wisst hat, dass der der Titel von der Audiophonic CD ist.
Genau und die Linkliste zu dieser Sendung, die werden wir auch nach der Sendung, werde ich die noch irgendwie schnell auf www.fritz.de veröffentlichen.
Wir sind ja schon kräftig am Mitschreiben.
Kräftig am Mitschreiben, da braucht dann also zu Hause nicht unbedingt jeder Mitschreiben.
Ja und wie gesagt, wenn er die Audiophonic CD zum Beispiel abwärmen wollte, die ist auch nicht besonders teuer, die kostet umgerechnet so ca. 24 Mark. Das ist also wirklich nicht die Rede.
Lohnt sich.
Ja, offensichtlich, da spielen wir auch noch ein paar Sachen von heute Abend denke ich mal. Ja, würde ich schon sagen. Außerdem reden wir heute Abend über Demos. Wo waren wir denn eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Ja, ich glaube wir waren stehen geblieben, eigentlich, dass man da mal was eine Demo ist.
Das hatten wir ja glaube ich geklärt, so mehr oder weniger.
Das hat man so halbwegs geklärt, ja. Ich kann es nicht jeder so vorstellen, aber es sind eben komplett selbstablaufende Sachen und wenn sie halt entsprechend gut gemacht sind, dann sind sie auch entsprechend beeindruckend.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, wenn ich da einen Film habe, ein MPEG, das da kommt, in hoher Qualität, das alles abgespielt wird?
Das ist eine andere Sache der Demoszene, dass eigentlich alles selbst gemacht ist und die Effekte, die da gezeigt werden, sind für gewöhnlich eigentlich Real-Time, dass nichts vorkalkuliert ist. Das ist alles Real-Time, so schnell wie der Rechner ist, auf dem es läuft, so gut läuft es, dann nimmt er auch ab.
Es gibt halt diesen Dreiklang von Grafik, Musik und Code, also dem programmiertechnischen Teil. Und das ist halt eins, was die Szene ausmacht, dass nicht nur die Leute, die jetzt, in Anführungsstrichen, kreativ sind, zeigen können, was sie drauf haben, sondern auch die Leute, die einfach code-mäßig was drauf haben und ein Superwerk programmieren können.
Das heißt, es reicht nicht, dass es geil aussieht und sich geil anhört. Es muss auch noch ein eleganter Code dabei sein.
Das wäre ideal, ja.
Das wäre dein Ideal?
Genau.
Woran erkenne ich den eleganten Code? Du merkst ja, wie viel Verständnis ich davon habe.
Ja, für online-Gewalt ist es manchmal so schwer zu erkennen, würde ich sagen. Also wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Thema beschäftigt hat und vielleicht auch aus Spielen kennt, was so möglich ist, und dann sieht man Sachen, wo man gedacht hätte, ne, das geht nicht, das gibt's einfach nicht, ja.
Nenn mal ein richtig schönes, krasses Beispiel.
Ein richtig schönes, krasses Beispiel. Es gibt eine Intro. Intro ist eine besondere Form von Demo, die ist nicht größer als 64 Kilobyte.
Muss man dazu sagen, es gibt auch noch 4 Kilobyte Intro. Es ist auch noch wieder extra.
Gut, das ist aber nochmal eine andere Sache. Jedenfalls gibt es da eine Intro, die nennt sich Das Produkt. Und in diesen 64 Kilobyte stecken ein 15-minütiger Soundtrack in CD-Qualität. Insgesamt über 19 Gigabyte an Daten, die alle errechnet werden mit einem Texturgenerator, mit einem Software-Synthesizer. Und das Ganze ist eine riesengeniale Show, die alles in einem super winzigen Pfeil drin ist. Und dann die 64 Kilobyte sich praktisch auffaltet.
Das heißt, das Ding würde theoretisch dann auf meinem Game Boy laufen?
Na ja, wenn der Game Boy im Pentium 3 drin wäre.
Das heißt, unter Pentium 3 brauch ich das Ding auch gar nicht?
Ja, nicht wirklich. Man kann eigentlich sagen, für diese ganzen Demos, die neueren Demos, die unter Windows laufen jetzt, wie auch meistens, weil frühere Demos, die liefen für gewöhnlich unter richtigem DOS-Site, DOS 6.2. Und da brauchte man nicht so einen schnellen Rechner. Da reichte für gewöhnlich halt, sicherlich 10 ist ja auch schon viele Jahre alt, hat alles mal angefangen auf 2.86, 3.86 Computern. Und ist dann halt auch mal anspruchsvoller geworden. Musste man halt auch schnellere Rechner haben, um eben die Demos dann auch in einer vernünftigen Qualität sich angucken zu können. Aber für die Windows-Demos generell kann man sagen, Pentium 3 aufwärts.
Und eine gute Grafikkarte möglichst, mit guter 3D-Geschleunigung.
Also so mein kleinen Siemens-Laptop mit 600 MHz und Pentium 3 sollte ich da lieber gar nicht erst mit diesem Codex füttern.
Da kann man schon was machen mit. Allerdings ist es schlecht, wenn er keine 3D-Karte drin hat, weil ohne 3D-Karte wird das Ding nicht laufen.
Doch, die hat er zumindest, das sind wieder Anleitungen.
Ich habe mit Sicherheit keine High-End-Konfiguration. Ich kann nur sagen, auf meinem Rechner das ist ein Pentium 3 450 mit 256 MB RAM und einer Nvidia TNT 2-Karte. Und darauf laufen eigentlich immer noch viele Demos in einer guten Qualität, kann man sagen.
Dieses Produkt, also das Produkt, das finde ich ja jetzt, das kribbelt ja jetzt gerade.
Wo kriege ich das her?
Zum Beispiel auch auf meiner Homepage.
Das gibt es aber auch vor allem auf der Homepage von Farbrausch, wo ich zufälligerweise auch Mitglied bin.
Das heißt, Farbrausch ist ein Verein?
Ja, richtig.
Das ist eine Demo-Gruppe.
Das ist ein loser Verbund von Leuten, mehr oder weniger, die sich zusammensetzen und zusammen Demos machen.
Gamer nennen das Clan, oder? Ist das so vergleichbar?
Ja, geht in die Richtung.
Ihr rennt jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht rum.
Aber die Homepage vom Internet, die könnt ihr euch gerne angucken. Das ist www.farb-rausch.de oder.com, wie ihr wollt..com..de gibt es auch? Wir packen das auch noch hinterher auf die Linkliste. Soll ich noch ein Häkchen ranmachen? Warum? Vielleicht verzieren oder so.
Ach so, eine kleine Gelande drumrum malen. Das würde mir sehr gut gefallen. Lass uns noch mal Musik von Sebastian bzw. Wayfinder hören, was ja ungefähr dasselbe ist. Du sagtest Track 5, Looking Back, The Race Part 3. The Race gab es schon mal von Yellow. Ist das in Anliegenung?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Also Musik von Sebastian, Wayfinder heißt das Projekt. The Race, ne, stopp. Looking Back. Verzeihung, ich hab das vergessen. Chaosradio 62 mit Musik von Wayfinder, was quasi dasselbe ist wie Sebastian, der hier sitzt. Er ist nämlich Teil der Democoder Szene und die Democoder Szene ist unser Thema heute Abend. Hier auf dem Telefon klingelt. Wollen wir mal rangehen? Ihr könnt mit uns telefonieren, weil der Blue Moon auf Fritz ist so eine Sendung, wo man anrufen kann und sich äußern kann. Die Nummer lautet so.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Und falls ihr gerade ganz spontan was zur Democoder Szene zu sagen habt, teilnehmen wollt oder gar nicht teilnehmen wollt.
Ich muss ein bisschen sagen, es ist nicht die Democoder Szene, sondern es ist die Demo Szene.
Die Demo Szene, ach so.
Für Demos braucht man Coder, da braucht man Grafiker und Musiker. Also mit Coder allein ist es nicht getan.
Das hat man mir falsch vermittelt. Ich geh mal hier ran. Hallo, hier ist Fritz, das Chaosradio. Ja, Mensch, jetzt hast du uns gekriegt.
Endlich.
Ah, verdammt.
Lässt du uns doch wieder weg.
Mir gerade leise ich natsch.
Ich muss kurz um die Scheiße kriechen.
Mensch, das ist das Kino im Kopf, ne?
Ein herrliches Bild, ja.
Hab ich ein paar Geräusche, die dazu passen?
Nee.
Ja, sag doch mal, wer du bist.
Der Ralf aus Malköln.
Der Ralf aus Malköln. Was kannst du denn für uns tun?
Ich für euch nichts, ihr für mich.
Ach Gott, also hör mal.
Ich hab gerade bei Farbbranche live klargemacht, das Produkt FR08, The Party 2064 Cardemo.
Runtergeholt.
Versucht zu starten, ist es echt schlecht, dass es live ist, aber es sagt TX Error.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, hast du eine beschissene Grafik?
Hast du da Dreigt X8?
Na, dann müsste es funktionieren.
Kann ich so konkret auch nichts sagen. Also auf meinem ganz durchschnittlichen Rechner läuft das eigentlich auch.
Jetzt haben wir doch wieder.
1333 und B ist jetzt nur verwundert.
Ich dachte, ich ruf jetzt an und dann war das frei.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab einen ganz normalen Durchschnittsrechner P3450 mit Windows 2000 drauf. Ich hab das mit ME geleistet. Ach, ME?
Kann man das an ME legen? Ach, ich weiß nicht.
Mit ME kenn ich mich nicht aus, aber ich würde auf jeden Fall mal sagen auf 95 oder 98.
Du rüstest auf überlegene Technologie auf und benutzt andere Systeme.
Hallo Niel, was wäre denn in diesem Fall die überlegene Technologie, die genau dieses Windows...
Eine andere Technologie?
Achso.
Nein, ich denke da persönlich, hm, vielleicht funktioniert das einfach nicht. Ich probier's halt nochmal.
Probier's nochmal.
Probier's nochmal, genau, es lohnt sich.
Schön, dass du deinen Anruf auf jeden Fall.
Tschüss, dir auch. Und hier haben wir noch einen. Hallo Chaosradio. Können wir jetzt bis 1 Uhr so weitermachen?
Nein, ja, ja, hier ist Nina.
Nina?
Hallo. Da. Gut, ja, ich wollte bloß eine ganz kleine konstruktive Kreative anbringen. Ähm, ihr unterhaltet euch da wie Fachidioten.
Wer glaubst du, was wir sind?
Na, ich glaube, dass ihr das seid. Deswegen sage ich jetzt ja, dass ihr euch so unterhaltet.
Ja, das müsste Chaosradio sein.
Das war jetzt der Vorwurf, aber du weißt ja, dagegen sein reicht nicht.
Nein, das war kein Vorwurf, das war eine Kritik.
Und was sollten wir jetzt deiner Meinung nach an unserem Verhalten ändern?
Ihr versucht da Begriffe zu erklären, die jeder weiß, aber Begriffe, die keiner weiß, erklärt ihr nicht?
Ja, frag doch einfach mal, welcher Begriff das ist.
Ist interaktiv, klicken Sie jetzt.
Welchen Begriff geht das denn?
Also zum Beispiel Cracken. Ihr kennt Crack und ihr kennt Crack Schokolade, aber was Cracken ist, weiß ich nicht. Darum geht es jetzt aber nicht, du sollst mir das nicht erklären. Und dann geht es darum, mit den Demos, ja, ihr unterhaltet euch da jetzt fast eine dreiviertel Stunde drüber. Und ich hab immer nicht begriffen, was jetzt sein soll, so richtig.
Okay, dann müssen wir das nochmal erklären. Dann erklären wir das jetzt nochmal und du bleibst bitte dran und hörst zu und sagst uns dann, nachdem wir das erklärt haben, ob wir das richtig erklärt haben.
Nein, halt, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Doch, das machen wir jetzt, doch, doch.
Du musst da durch.
Da musst du jetzt durch.
Nein, ich bezahlt aber nicht.
Okay, dann erklären wir es jetzt ohne, dass du dran bleibst und du rufst.
Nein, Moment, ich wollte ja noch was sagen. Grüße? Nein. Das gibt es nicht.
Nell, jetzt lass sie doch mal reden.
Ja, jetzt hab ich jetzt schon fast wieder vergessen, weil ich mich so anstrengen muss, hier mal zu Wort zu kommen.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich mach mal unsere Mikrofone aus. So, jetzt warte, Achtung. So, jetzt sind drei Mikrofone von vieren aus und meins mach ich jetzt auch.
Gut, also ich wollte nur noch sagen, dass irgendwie sonst sehr interessant war und dass im... Hallo?
Ja, ich kann nicht. Ich hab mein Mikro aus.
Nein, du solltest es nicht ausmachen mal.
Ach so, dann mach ich unsere Mikros jetzt wieder an.
Ich rufe doch nicht keinen an, ey.
Na gut, Nina. Nein, aber du hast doch... also hier hören doch noch Leute zu. Ich dachte, es reicht dir mit denen zu reden.
Nein, ich will nicht, dass Leute zuhören. Ich wollte euch das sagen, weil es mir da eher wer dazuhört noch.
Ja, dann ändern wir das jetzt und...
Okay, wir versuchen nichtsdestotrotz noch mal Demos zu erklären. Also ich dachte, es wäre...
Ja, ja, dann darfst du das nicht mehr bezahlen muss, ja?
Ja, ja, nee, das ist klar.
Mein Gott, jetzt hab ich schon wieder vergessen, was ich sagen wollte, aber Moment, das fällt mir nicht... E-Mail, fucking E-Mail, ey. Ja, jetzt weiß ichs wieder. Ich wollte sagen, dass ähm... Die Coverversion von Rammstein, Drachman...
Oder?
Ja.
Ja, ist ein Entfundstück von Norbert, dem Kollegen aus dem Blackboard Jungle hier auf Fritz. Ja, werd ich ausrichten. Nina, danke für deinen Anruf. Während wir erklären... Wir machen jetzt erstmal Musik. Ihr könnt uns auch gerne weiter anrufen und uns beschimpfen. Unter dieser Leugnung.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Dennis, das ist das Chaosradio auf Fritz und da darf man mitreden. Demoszene ist unser Thema. Ich würde sagen, wir machen trotzdem erstmal ein bisschen Musik und dann erklären wir nochmal, was das Thema ist, weil offensichtlich... Ich dachte, wenn ich es verstehe, verstehen es die anderen auch. Schade eigentlich. 23 Uhr. Und zwar das Chaosradio Nummer 62 mit der Demoszene als Thema. Wer eben noch gehört hat, dass ich das andere zu gesagt habe, der hat das nicht gehört. Der Zugast im Studio ist Talonil, Krest und Sebastian. Die Musik kommt gerade von Sebastian und das nennt sich Wayfinder, das Projekt, was er da gemacht hat. Wir wollten nochmal erklären, was die Demoszene ist, aber vorher müssen wir telefonieren. Hier hat nämlich Jakob angerufen. Hallo Jakob. Schieß los.
Also ich hab mir vor 26 Tagen dieses Parlakt runtergezogen.
Also ich hab da so eine, hier in so einer Form gefunden, wo ich mich da ein bisschen umteile.
Ich muss sagen, das ist ziemlich cool.
Also wirklich 64K.
Also es ist auch unstreitbar das beste 64K Intro, das bislang gemacht wurde. Das ist ganz klare Sache.
Wenn man das startet, der entpackt zwar ein bisschen länger und macht und tut, aber die Grafik ist cool.
Also das ist so ziemlich mit der Qualität von Quake 2 vergleichbar.
Moment mal, ernsthaft, also so gut?
Es ist exzellent.
Es ist wirklich gut.
Und es ist noch exzellenter, wenn man immer bedenkt, dass es 64K sind.
Ja, das ist richtig. Allein schon Wahnsinn, ist überhaupt irgendwas von 64K, was läuft?
Also Quake in 64K ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nicht direkt, nee.
Es gibt zwar Descent in 4K, aber Quake in 64.
Bei dem Descent in 4K ist es halt so eine Descent Engine, die ist schon ein paar Jahre älter. Und das wurde mal tatsächlich in 4K eingepackt.
Jetzt muss man vielleicht erst erklären, was Descent ist. Descent ist ein Spiel, ein Computerspiel, was so ungefähr 5, 6 Jahre alt ist. Das war eines der ersten Spiele, wo man komplette Bewegungsfreiheit im 3D-Raum hatte. Man hatte so ein komisches Schiff, mit dem man herumgeflogen ist in eine Schwerelosigkeit. Und das war halt super aufwändig, kam irgendwie auf zwei CDs und cooles Soundtrack.
Und ein Drecksack ist hingegangen und hat das in 4K gemacht.
Das war auch gemein.
Schöne Dekadent.
Und in diesem 4K ist auch noch Sound drin.
Ach echt? Jakob, klingt das interessant gerade?
Ja.
Wo kriegt man das, Jungs?
Das kriegst du auf meiner Homepage.
Ich hab so den Verdacht, als würde alles auf deine Homepage.
Ja, also ich hab so circa Mitte 96, da hab ich eine kleine Sammlung in erster Linie von 64K Intros, also nicht nur die besten Sachen, weil sonst würde es zu viel werden für den Speicherplatz, den ich jetzt zur Verfügung habe. Und halt auch Traffic Technik wird sonst zu teuer werden. Aber so ab Mitte 96 bis zu den aktuellen Partys sind halt die besten 64K Intros und eine Handvoll von 4K Intros. Und da meines Erachtens hab ich da auch diese 4K Intro mit der Decent Engine.
Was nennt sich?
Sanction heißt die Gruppe.
Ist aber nicht...
Und nennt sich Omniscient.
Ist aber nicht spielbar, ne?
Nein, das ist nicht spielbar.
Ist auch selbst ablaufend.
Guck mal, ich hab mir manchmal so Zeitungen aus Polen mitbringen lassen und da gab's auch manchmal so Sachen aus der Szene, also Bilder, Music Tracks und auch eben solche Demos, ne?
Polen ist eine starke Basis für die Szene auf jeden Fall. Da kommen sehr viele gute Musiker her und auch sehr gute Coda.
Sehr gute Gruppe aus Polen ist Pulse, zumindest aus der Vergangenheit so.
Die waren also noch eblich kleiner als 64K, aber eben ohne 3D-Unterstützung, also es war eigentlich alles noch Software, aber auch das ist ihm ziemlich gut gemacht.
Ja, also es gibt einige sehr, sehr coole Sachen auf sehr, sehr kleinem Raum. Das ist halt auch ein Teilaspekt der Demoscene, dass man versucht, aus so wenig wie möglich technischen Mitteln so viel wie möglich an AHA-Effekt drauf zu holen.
Das ist eigentlich ein ursprünglicher Punkt der Demoscene, dass man eben aus den Mitteln, die man zur Verfügung hat, möglichst viel rausholen will.
Das Min-Max-Prinzip.
Ja, weißte, ich wollte noch was sagen.
Und zu?
Nochmal zu den Computer-Blumuen. Könnt ihr vielleicht so was machen, was sich über Takten dreht und Case Modding oder sowas?
Über was? Über Takten. Über Takten? Ah, ein HLW, die Overclocking Radio.
Kannst du mal dein Radio über Takten?
Nein, ein Radio über Takten, Quatsch.
Offensichtlich ist es nicht unbedingt Wunsch des Chaos Computer Club. Overclocking, nee.
Vielleicht der späteren Sendung.
Da fällt mir gerade noch so nie bei.
Heute ja nicht, das eh nicht.
Heute nicht, ist ja klar, ich meine, keine Ahnung, nächste Woche oder in zwei Wochen oder sowas.
Naja, nehmen wir es mal als Themenvorschlag auf. Das muss ja eh dann erst mal durchs Plenum, denke ich mal.
Alles klar.
Durchs Plenum in die Ausschüsse und dann nochmal ins Plenum. Jakob, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Alles klar, danke.
Mach's gut, tschüss. Falls ihr auch hier anrufen wollt, im Chaosradio Nummer 62 auf Fritz, nehmt diese Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam 7097 110.
So much for me here.
So wir wurden gemeint, mitschneidig recht auszuspielen, das wir hiermit getan haben. Jetzt kann ich nur leider nicht sagen, um was es sich da gehandelt hat. Kreis, hast du das Album?
Das ist ja gerade von Dr. Awesome. Im Real Life ist er als Björn Linde bekannt und ist halt auch ein sehr bekannter Musiker aus der Szene, schon seit vielen Jahren.
Wer macht inzwischen Musik für Computerspiele in England?
Warum reden wir drüber? Wir reden drüber, weil es ist ein Chaosradio, Chaosradio 62 auf Fritz. Und die Demoszene ist unser Thema und angerufen hat. Blow, bist du noch dran?
Ja, also erst mal eine kurze Frage an Crest oder Wayfinder. Ich habe heute im IRC versprochen, dass ich die Sendung aufzeichne. Und jetzt bin ich um 11 vollkommen bereit nach Hause gekommen, weil ich dachte, die Sendung ist nächste Woche, nächste Woche und habe jetzt keine Aufnahme gestartet. Macht ihr davon einer?
Ja, es gibt einen Witschnitt, den kann man dann später beim FDP-Server vom CCC downloaden. Und dazu muss ich jetzt noch sagen, der CCC hatte angekündigt, dass es einen MP3-Stream von der Sendung geben sollte. Leider gibt es den aus technischen Gründen nicht. Aber ihr könnt über die Fritz-Homepage als ReaAudio im Internet mitlauschen. Das klappt auch so einigermaßen, weil der Server soll wohl nicht der belastungsfähigste sein.
Wir schneiden das mit, ich hoffe zumindest, dass klappt irgendwie. Und naja, der Internet-Stream ist halt gerade etwas braun.
Aber auf jeden Fall kann man das später vom FDP-Server, vom CCC, runterladen als MP3?
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Fritz-Server.
Oder vom Fritz-Server. Auf jeden Fall ist es dort, was zu runterladen gibt von der Sendung.
Na gut, aber wenn du es jetzt ankündigst, werden es die Leute, die es jetzt gerade nicht hören können, auch nicht hören können.
Na ja, das wird sich, denke ich, schon rumsprechen.
Buschtrommeln werden so...
Jetzt mal zum Thema hier.
Der ein oder andere wird mich vielleicht kennen. Also die Berliner Demoszenen zumindest.
Ja, ich kenn dich ja zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich kenn dich ja auch.
Du hast doch meine Telefonnummer, glaube ich.
Es kann sein, dass ich deine Nummer nicht mehr habe. Auf nirgendsige Rechte schachte, würdest du das.
Könnt ihr das irgendwie morgen beim Frühstück klären?
Also ich finde es...
Was machst du denn, Blo? Was machst du denn in der Demoszene?
Na ja, sagen wir so, ich betreibe mit einem der Channel der Demoszene. Dieser Kodas GR auf IRCnet, da bin ich Operator drinnen und das bin ich seit 1996 oder 1997.
Auf dem Channel bin ich übrigens auch Operator.
Ja, natürlich wollte ich nicht Nachrede stellen, aber ich lese mit in der Demoszene seit Svidonet, also so 1994 ungefähr.
Aber ich meine, die Demoszene hat ja eigentlich mehr mit Zuhören und Zugucken zu tun als mit zu lesen, oder?
Naja, zu lesen, die Szenen treffen sich ja dann natürlich auch im Internet, also eben vorwiegend im IRC und hier in Deutschland vorwiegend im IRCnet. Und da haben sie halt ihre Channels, wo man sich dann halt zum Talk trifft.
Aber Blow, das heißt, du bist dann Channel-Operator und machst aber selber keine Demos?
Nee, nee, früher mal Musik, aber das ist dann irgendwann eingeschlafen und irgendwann keine Ahnung, keine Zeit mehr für gehabt.
Und was reizt dich dann noch daran? Also ich mein, mich reizt da dran draufklicken, angucken, danke.
Nee, also ich renne auch begeistert auf diverse Demopartys, zumindest wenn sie in der Nähe sind. Aber naja, das ist halt so, was schaffen die Leute immer mehr rauszuholen aus den Dingern? Also es ist einfach so dieses, zum Beispiel wenn Pick-Pen aus Berlin ist, der ist so ein 4K-Coder, also 4 Kilo weit. Und was der aus einem, weiß nicht, was der da rausholt, ist schon echt, also wenn man sich so anguckt, diesen Schaffensprozess von ihm und was der da rausholt, ist echt beeindruckend.
Stimmt allerdings.
Also das würde ich nicht mehr schaffen.
Das ist doch brutal viel Arbeit, oder? Ich mein, so ein Ding, also 4K ist ja nichts, aber das, wie lang braucht man da?
Also man muss sich da schon richtig reinstürzen und da auch richtig viel Zeit investieren. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man irgendwie dahin gehen könnte und sagen, ich mach das jetzt mal schnell, 4K sind schnell zusammen. Sondern es geht halt darum, möglichst krass zu optimieren. Und das dauert halt auch eine Weile.
Was ist eine Weile im Zahlen? Also Wochen?
Monate, Wochen, Monate. Also da kann man mit rechnen, dass ein richtig gutes 4 KB Intro mindestens ein paar Monate braucht.
Wenn das einer alleine macht. Da hat das 4K dieses Demo fertig kriegen wollen und der war vollkommen am Ende, als die Deadline vorüber war. Die Deadline heißt halt, da ist Endabgabeschluss. Und er hatte halt bis zu diesem Abgabeschluss programmiert oder zumindest sehr wenig geschlafen bis dahin. Er war auch ziemlich tot danach.
Wer hat diesen Abgabeschluss festgelegt?
Das müssen wir vielleicht kurz erklären, die Mecca.
Ich denke auch gerade.
Die Mecca ist eine der größten Demos für die Partys. Die ist die größte in Deutschland. Da treffen sich jährlich zu Ostern immer so zwischen 1000 und 1200 Leute. Die bringen also in eine große Mehrzweckhalle. Da werden Tische aufgestellt, jeder bringt seinen Computer mit und dann sitzen da 1000 Leute, alle vernetzt. Und vorne ist ein großer Big-Screen, 4x6 Meter, worauf dann Produktionen gezeigt werden können. Da gibt es dann Wettbewerbe, haben wir vorhin schon kurz drüber geredet, Wettbewerbe in Grafik, Musik und Demo-Intro-Kategorien, auch auf verschiedenen Systemen. Und da gibt es dann halt eine Deadline, bis dahin kann man die Sachen abgeben und die werden dann hintereinander gezeigt und dann gibt es ein Publikumsvoting, welches dann am Ende gewinnt.
Wann findet es statt, die Mecca?
Die Mecca findet es zu Ostern.
Das ist immer von Karfreitag bis Ostermondag.
Immer an demselben Ort oder?
Immer an demselben Ort. Die letzten Jahre. Wo denn?
In Falling Bostel.
In Falling Bostel?
Ja, im schönen Falling Bostel.
Da musste ich mal mit meinen Eltern in den Urlaub fahren. Soltau Falling Bostel ist ja grau.
Tolle Gegend, ja.
Und bemerkenswerterweise hatte der Film 23 auch Falling Bostel mit im Film drinnen.
Ja, der Film 23, ich weiß nicht, ob die ihn alle kennen, aber ich denke mal schon, da stranden die Hauptfiguren halt am Bahnhof in Falling Bostel. Das führt, wenn der Film auf so einer Party gespielt wird, auch regelmäßig zu Jubel aus dem Ort.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Blow, noch was von dir? Alles klar, dann danke ich für deine Anruf. Mach's gut, ciao. Wir reden immer über Intro. Warum heißen Intros Intro? Ich nenne es jetzt mal Filmchen. Was macht das Filmchen zum Intro und beziehungsweise wann bleibt es Filmchen?
Filmchen heißt ja, dass die Sachen vorberechnet sind und praktisch die Einzelbilder hintereinander.
Das ist klar. Also ich sehe dann dieses Demo auf meinem Bildschirm.
Also Intro hat was mit der Größe zu tun. Alles, was über 64 Kilobyte groß ist, ist im Prinzip schon eine Demo. Und alles, was drunter liegt, ist ein Intro.
Woher kommt der Name?
Also Intro wie Introduction. Damit hat es eigentlich angefangen. Die Introductions zu den gekreckten Spielen, die haben sich dann verselbstelligt.
Also die Demo-Szene hat sich eigentlich als Nabelschau dieser Cracker-Szene entwickelt.
Das hatten wir ja am Anfang mal, aber ich dachte mir, wer noch eingeschaltet hat, der hat das noch nicht.
Und umso bunter das dann ist, umso besser.
Was seid ihr eigentlich so für Leute? Leben kann man davon nicht, von Demos oder? Nee, sicherlich nicht. Leben kann man davon nicht. Es kostet monatelang Zeit. Wovon lebt ihr?
Also ich bin Student und arbeite noch nebenher, um mir mein Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen.
Und Crest?
Also Jobtechnisch sieht bei mir zurzeit sehr schlecht aus, finanziell ebenfalls. Also wie es da weitergeht, kann ich zurzeit nicht sagen. Aber auf jeden Fall, also geldmäßig habe ich mit der Computerei noch nie was in der Richtung gemacht.
Ach echt nicht, du schreibst Demos, aber verdienst...
Ich schreibe keine Demos an. Ich hab mal einen Mailbox-Betrieb, das ist schon einige Jahre her. Da war ich halt im Filonet und da habe ich dann auch mal zeitgleich einen Mailbox betrieben. Später dann nur noch einen Fido-Mailer, dass man eben anrufen konnte, Files-Requests. Also wer jetzt so ein bisschen mit der Filonet-Technologie auskennt, weil jetzt auch noch die ganze Mailbox-Szene abzureißen, das wäre ein bisschen zu viel für die Sektor.
Ja doch.
Was treibt euch da um? Was seid ihr für Menschen? Ihr macht auf mich einen vergleichsweise normalen Eindruck.
Eigentlich sind Demos hier auch ganz normale Menschen.
Ich persönlich sehe für mich den Sinn der Demos-Szene darin, dass ich andere Leute treffe, die ähnliche Interessen haben wie ich, die gerne kreativ sind und gerne was mit eigenen Händen machen. Also jetzt nicht basteln oder so, sondern die gerne was auf die Beine stellen. Einfach was Cooles herzeigen, was sie gemacht haben und das auch anderen zeigen.
Du wolltest auch was sagen, Tim.
Ich wollte auch was sagen.
Tim, sag doch mal was.
Rede mit uns.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, wie ihr diese spezielle Motivation beschreiben würdet, die die Leute treibt, die sich aktiv mit der Demoszene auseinandersetzen. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die sehr intensiv... Was ist eigentlich mit der Musik?
Ich weiß es auch nicht so genau. Dann beschweren sich hier wieder alle, dass diese Musik drunter liegt. Also wir wollen doch immer alle durch.
Ja, aber man macht doch jetzt mal Musik dann.
Willst du weiter reden oder wollen wir eine richtige Platte spielen, um den Jungs Bedenkzeit zu lassen?
Meinetwegen auch das.
Chaosradio 62 auf Fritz. Die Demoszene ist unser Thema und die Jungs haben eben die Frage gestellt. Tim, würdest du bitte die Frage nochmal wiederholen? Das war mir zu schwer, um das zu merken.
Entschuldigung.
Was denn?
Mikroprobleme.
Kannst du das bitte nochmal wiederholen?
Du sollst die Frage nochmal stellen, die du eben gestellt hast, wo die Jungs jetzt drei Minuten Zeit hatten, darüber nachzudenken, zu sich zu finden.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen über die Motivation gesprochen. Ja, ich hab halt gefragt, was eigentlich sozusagen die spezielle Motivation ist, die die Leute jetzt in diese Szene reinbringen. Weil zunächst einmal klingt es halt auch wie eine ganz normale weitere Hacksportart, irgendwie mit einer besonderen Ausprägung, was es sicherlich auch ist. Aber dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, was gerade daran reizt. Ich denke einerseits, dass es irgendwie eine besondere Mischung ist, weil es sowohl das Programmieren als auch das aktiv schöne Gestalten zusammenbringt. Und das eben sowohl in grafischer Hinsicht als auch in musikalischer Hinsicht. Also eigentlich alles, was so irgendwie Pläsier macht, zusätzlich dann noch erweitert irgendwie um die Technik. Also der reine Hacksport, irgendwie so das Programmieren. Und Grafik und Musik, das ist irgendwie... Da gibt es so einen schönen Satz in der Hackerethik, der heißt, you can create art and beauty with a computer. Und das finde ich irgendwie drückt halt die Demoszene in einem ganz besonderen Maße aus.
Ist das die Meinung der Demoszene auch?
Ja, da kann ich mich nur anschließen. Das ist schön gesagt, ja.
Das Demomanifest.
Sollten wir vielleicht in Stein meißeln und vor dem Fritz-Studio aufstehen.
Fest, erzähl doch mal eben, wie das heißt, was wir hier hören, du hast es ausgesucht. Also das ist eines meiner ausgesuchten Module, es ist von Star Fox, so nennt er sich in der Szene und der Realname ist Oliver Schumann und der Titel nennt sich Swift Exposure.
Und das Ganze ist auch released worden auf dem Tokyo Dawn Label. Tokyo Dawn, ja.
Tokyo Dawn Records.
Genau, den Link können wir mit auf die Linkliste. Also das Label nennt sich also komplett Tokyo Dawn Records.
Findet ihr nachher auch schon später am Tag unter www.fritz.de Ja. Tim, du guckst mich so an, als würdest du was sagen wollen. Was willst du sagen, Tim?
Weiß nicht, ich hab das Mikro hängen. Ich hab das Mikro erwartet, bis du aufhörst zu reden.
Achso, ja dann mach ich dein Mikrofon jetzt erstmal wieder aus. Weil das braucht nämlich der Matthias jetzt. 23.32 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter, trocken bleibt die Nacht bei 17 bis 14 Grad. Morgen dann Schauer und Gewitter, bis 26 Grad, die Meldung mit Matthias Gerkhoff.
Die Herkunft von Samuel J. Merkhoff, ein Gründer der CDU nahe an Schweizer Norfolk Stiftung, ist offenbar aufgeklärt. Der ehemalige CDU-Finanzberater Weihrauch soll das Geld in eine Mitarbeiter der Schweizer UBS-Bankenbar übergeben haben, berichtet die Bildzeitung. Der Bankangestellte sei auch bereit vor dem Spenden-Untersuchungsausschuss auszusagen, heißt es. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat sich grundsätzlich für eine Betätigung der Bundeswehr in einem NATO-Einsatz in Mazedonien ausgesprochen. Deutschland werde sich seinen internationalen Verpflichtungen nicht entziehen können, sagte er in einem Interview. Wegen der Ermordung eines Obdachlosen hat das Landgericht Schwerin zwei junge Männer zur lebenslanger Haft bzw. sechseinhalb Jahren Jugendhaft verurteilt. Die Angeklagten hatten den zwar 50-jährigen Mann im vergangenen Sommer in Wismar so schwer misshandelt, dass er wenig später starb. Mehrere hundert Berliner Schüler sind heute für mehr Mut und Toleranz im Alltag auf die Straße gegangen. Kinder und Jugendliche von etwa 20 Schulen hatten sich zu einem Sternmarsch versammelt, der bis zum Brandenburger Tor führte. Frankreich hat heute die Wehrpflicht abgeschafft. Der Erfolg bei der Umwandlung der Streitkräfte in eine Berufsarmee habe diesen Schritt ein Jahr früher als geplant ermöglicht, erklärte Präsident Chirac. Die Armee verfüge über genügend Freiwillige.
Vielen Dank Matthias. Ich bin gespannt, was ihr. Chaosradio 262 auf Fritz, die Demoszene, unser Thema. Und das war gerade Musik aus der Demoszene und zwar von Wayfinder, der sich auch hier im Studio befindet. Der heißt aber anders, wenn er sich hier im Studio befindet, da ist nämlich Sebastian. Außerdem Crest und Tim.
Ja, kannst du mir mal eine Mate geben?
Eine Mate?
Ja, eine Mate.
Ach so, eine Mate. Ach da hinten ist der Kasten. Ja, hat hier los ist. So bitte Tim.
Super.
Ja, musst du jetzt erst trinken oder kannst du direkt...
Nö, ich wollte dir immer was erzählen.
Erzähl mir mal was.
Also im August... Was machst du denn im August, Holger?
Im August, im August... Im August...
Im August...
Gleite jetzt bitte nicht in den Hautsträum ab.
Im August mache ich...
Das sieht man jetzt nicht an der Frühschicht.
Du hast also noch nichts vor? Dann könntest du ja z.B. auf die Hell kommen.
Dann könnte ich auf die Hell kommen. Was ist das?
Das ist die Hacker-Konferenz namens Hacking at Large. Oder auch Hell 2001, die findet in Holland statt.
Wann im August?
Das ist der 10. bis 12. August. Also so ein verlängertes Wochenende.
Da kann ich sogar...
Freitags, Freitags und Sonntags. In Enschede, also ziemlich nah an der deutschen Grenze.
Das ist jetzt so ein Freigelände in der Innenstadt, ne?
Ich dachte, das war Eschede.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht wurde es zwischenzeitlich auch erwogen, aber das Gelände, was sie dann doch ausgewählt haben, hat entscheidende Vorteile. Es ist nämlich im Gegensatz zu dieser Sprengzone, irgendwie serienmäßig mit 2 Gigabit Internetversorgung pro Sekunde ausgerichtet und das geht dann auch ziemlich direkt dahin, wo alle Wege ziemlich kurz sind überall hin. Also man ist mehr oder minder auf den europäischen Backbone direkt draufgeschaltet. Das ist halt das Universitätsgelände in Enschede, so ein riesiger Campus mit Wiesen, und da wird dann irgendwie gehackt. Und da kommen sie dann halt wieder alle mit Zelten über 3 Tage und wie das eben schon vor 4 Jahren auch in Holland war und auch vor 8 Jahren.
Nochmals Datum?
10. bis 12. August ist das glaube ich.
bis 12. August. Wo wir gerade bei August sind, das nächste Chaosradio gibt es nächsten Monat, also quasi ausnahmsweise mal nicht am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, sondern am ersten Mittwoch im Folgemonat und dann im selben Monat nochmal am letzten Mittwoch, was daran liest, dass ich ansonsten einfach einen Kreislauf Kollaps kriegen würde. Das ist wirklich irre. Die Dinge, von denen ich Kreislauf Kollaps kriege, werden einfach abgeschafft. Wir haben ja Mitleid mit dir. Wenigstens einer.
Der CCC hat Mitleid mit Holger Gnadein.
Leute spendet.
Können wir jetzt zur Sache hier?
Ja, die Direktorsaktion Kufen für Heul.
Gut, wir sprachen über die Demoszene, glaube ich.
Genau, wir sprachen über die Demoszene.
Du musst in das Mikro reinfliegen, so leid es mir tut.
Ich würde dazu sagen, der Titel, der da gerade im Hintergrund laufen lasst, den müsst ihr dann nochmal neu anspielen, weil der ist zu gut.
Viel neu anspielen.
Es ist darauf, wenn wir gesprochen haben, dass wir das nicht ausspielen.
Was mich nochmal interessieren würde, wäre, ob uns Leute zuhören, die selber in der Demoszene coden oder zumindest ähnliche Dinge tun, wenn sie sich vielleicht auch nicht so sehr der Szene selber zugehörig fühlen, die halt konkret Software schreiben für Demos, für Sachen, die nicht unbedingt Tabellenkalkulationsprogramme sind, wo man irgendwie Cut und Paste machen muss und sonst irgendeinen sogenannten Wirtschaftswert haben, sondern halt einfach schöne Sachen.
Die Nummer unter der ihr euch melden könnt, wenn ihr euch jetzt gerade mal angesprochen gefühlt habt, ist die hier.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Das ist deine Musik, Sebastian, was ist denn?
Ja, der Track ist da irgendwie auf der CD drauf, aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie der da aufgekommen ist.
Gut, dann werden wir nochmal in die CD-Reinigress mitgebracht. Jetzt gibt es Frederik Moby Motte aus Frankreich mit Flow, auf der Audiophonik ebenfalls vertreten und wo man die bestellen kann im Internet, das könnt ihr nachlesen unter www.fritzd.de, wenn diese Sendung vorbei ist.
Das war's für heute.
Chaosradio 62 auf Fritz, die Demoszene ist unser Thema und wir wollten Leute sprechen, die vielleicht auch selber koden in dieser Demoszene. Unsere Nummer ist die 0331 70 97 110 und Lenny hat angerufen. Hallo Lenny.
Lenny?
Hey, es funktioniert! Das war menschliches Versagen. Ne, ne, guten Abend Lenny.
Hallo. Jo, jo, also ich kode so in der Gegend rum. Also Grafik, Formierung und so. Für eine richtige Demo, die fertig geworden ist, hat es leider noch nicht erreicht.
Warst du schon mal auf einer Party oder so? Warst du schon mal auf einer Party, auf einer Demo-Party?
Ja, auf der Mecha-Symposium war ich. War schon dieses Jahr, oder?
Warst du dann dieses Jahr? Und wie fandst du die Party?
Was programmierst du?
In was?
Ja, in was und auch was programmierst du?
Also größtenteils DirectX und in C++.
Mit Visual C++ sozusagen?
Ne, mit VATCOM C. Ja, ich bin da irgendwie so drin geschlittert, gab's günstig, naja, bin ich bei VATCOM geblieben.
Und hast du den Eindruck, dass die meisten Leute mit C++ programmieren?
Würde ich sagen, ja C und Assembler halt.
Und wie ist so das Verhältnis zwischen Assembler und Nicht-Assembler?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall die Geschwindigkeit.
Ne, das ist mir bewusst, aber ich meine, wie viele Leute programmieren jetzt in Assembler und wie viele Leute programmieren in C++?
Achso, na, ich würde sagen, bei den Demos wird wohl C vorherrschen. Bei den 4 Kilo, 64 Kilo vielleicht auch noch natürlich Assembler. Wegen der Größe einfach.
Klar, stimmt.
Das heißt, die Intros sind sozusagen mehr die Spezialität der Assembler pur, oder? Ja, würde ich so sagen.
Das sind sowieso mehr so die Frickler, die sich dann wirklich ins kleinste Detail noch reinoptimieren.
Und was machst du und was programmierst du konkret? Also, was kommt dabei raus?
Also klar, aber zum Beispiel, also ich bin ja immer der Meinung, dass diese Demos noch zu fair rendert sein müssen.
Erklär mal für die Holger Kleinst dieser Welt bitte.
Also du meinst, ohne die Hardware-Unterstützung des Grafik-Subsystems zu benutzen.
Genau.
Das meinst du, ne?
Alles noch richtig handgecoded. Und naja, da hab ich halt mal so eine Engine programmiert, also eine 3D-Engine, die eben dieses tut. Und solche Sachen, grafische Effekte, Radial Blur und naja, diese typischen Sachen erstmal. Was man ja sicherlich oft wiederfindet in den Demos und ein kleines Soundsystem. Und war auf dem besten Wege, da irgendwie meine Demos zu zimmern. Aber es hat sich dann wieder ein bisschen im Winde verlaufen, also im Sand vielmehr. Weil, wie du sagst, Grafiker hab ich nicht zur Hand, Kontohofen nicht direkt empfinden.
Wir könnten ja hier mal so eine kleine Tauschbörse einrichten. Wir rufen die Grafiker an und wir leiten dann die Nummern weiter.
Es gibt doch nicht genug Channels, Seiten, wo er sich einen Grafiker suchen kann, oder?
Gibt es Programmierer, die die Demo komplett alleine machen? Es gibt sowohl Musik, Grafik und auch Code.
Der bereits erwähnte Pick-Pen zum Beispiel macht die Musik und die Grafik und den Code alles selber. Und da gibt es auch noch einige andere, die das können.
Aber das sind auch weniger als alle anderen.
Also es ist natürlich schwieriger, Leute zu finden, die alles drei können. Es gibt viele Leute, die Grafik und Musik können zum Beispiel, oder Musik und Coden. Aber Grafik und Coden zum Beispiel habe ich festgestellt, das verträgt sich nicht so gut miteinander.
Ah, so Grafik ist nun gar nicht meins. Mit Zeichnen bin ich nicht so.
Ja, wo soll er hin, damit er einen Grafiker findet?
Ja, also du kannst beim ISC gehen.
Entweder per ISC natürlich. Es gibt also auf dem ISC-Net, da gibt es einen Channel Coders. Zum Beispiel, da könntest du mal versuchen, eine Anfrage. Das ist ein englischer Channel, also solltest du englisch können.
Und dann gibt es auch noch für die Grafiker direkt den Channel Pixel. Da hängen auch immer eine ganze Menge Grafiker rum. Und da gibt es auch bestimmt Leute, die Interesse haben, an einer Demo mitzuwirken.
Außerdem gibt es dann im Internet noch Portale, Szene-Portale und ein sehr gutes ist da bei Orange Juice. Das ist ein sehr gutes Szene-Portal. Darüber könntest du bestimmt auch eventuell Hilfe finden.
Ja, und hast du auch eine Anzeige reingesetzt?
Ja, Lenni von Nix kommt.
Einfach mal die News reinsetzen und dann abwarten, ob nicht eine Reaktion kommt.
Ja, naja, gut, weil die Sache ist ja, es wäre natürlich günstig, wenn es dann natürlich auch einer in Berlin wäre, weil alle so über E-Mail, E-GwC, E-GwC, auf das alles so klappt.
Also es klappt eigentlich schon. Also es gibt so viele Demo-Gruppen, wo nicht alle Leute in einer Stadt wohnen.
Das kann auch gerne über verschiedene Länder verteilt sein.
Ja, aber für doch so eine Demo, das klappt so, ja.
Na ja, du musst du selber ausfinden, ob du dafür geeignet bist, so zu machen. Also ich kann dir nicht mal helfen.
Du musst mich nicht verweilen lassen.
Lenny, viel Erfolg auf deinem Weg.
Ja, möchte ich natürlich noch die ganze Demo-Group hier so grüßen. Und vor allem die ganzen Mecha-Symposium Creator.
Herzlichen Dank. Lenny, danke für deinen Anruf.
Alles klar.
Tschüss. Hallo Jörg.
Ja, hallo, grüß euch Chaos Leute.
Das möchtest du mir nicht sagen, dass du auch noch Demos programmierst?
Ja auch, ich hab mal Assembler gelernt. Software-Entwickler, kann ich mich auch schimpfen. Hab schon lange nicht mehr in Assembler programmiert.
Was für ein Assembler?
Ich Assembler, Kaufmachines-Assembler. Also Assembler ist Maschinensprache, ist die Grundlage jeder Programmierung, was man kann.
Das ist mir bewusst, weil ich meine, für welchen Prozessor.
Ich hab auch Vortran 77 gemacht und Kobol und so was, alles C und Pascal. Aber das ist, ich programmiere jetzt ganz anders. Und zwar programmiere ich aufgrund der Assembler-Grundlage, Texte. Und ich werde, ich bin eingeladen worden von Christian und von Jörg am Montag zum Blue Moon. Um 22 Uhr. Und ich mache selbst die Bulletten mit und einen Polo-Whisky und dann werde ich mal versuchen, mein Demo vorzustellen, wenn es möglich ist. Wenn nicht, bin ich einfach nur da.
Was für ein Demo wird es?
Das ist ein Demo aus der Wissenschaft und zwar aus der Oberung des Weltenraums.
Hat das dann so ein Hörspiel-Charakter?
Nie mehr so ein Wissensgebiet-Charakter, was andere Jungen gibt. Und andere junge Leute dazu animieren soll, konkrete Demos mit entsprechenden Musik-Backgrounds zu gestalten. Da ich immer auf dem Klo bin. So ist das ungefähr gedacht.
Und wie hast du das vorgestellt?
Ich frag mich auch, Jörg, ich verstehe dich gerade gar nicht. Wir kennen uns doch jetzt schon so lange.
Ja.
Erklär mal, was du da genau vorhast. Wir reden über Demos. Also die kleinen Dinge auf dem Computer, die da bunt sind.
Ich will ja nur die Anhörung geben, damit beim nächsten Mal da was bei rauskommt. Und ihr euch da dann erfreuen könnt an den Demos, den die jungen Leute aufgrund der Fragen, die ich stelle, wo ich auch einen Preis aussetze und ein hunderter Opfer, der die Fragen richtig beantwortet. Und der hat dann schon die Möglichkeit, sich damit Material zu besorgen, dass er also so ein Demo machen kann, was auch wirklich abläuft im Radio. So habe ich mir das vorgestellt.
Also das war jetzt quasi Werbung für den Blumen am nächsten Montag, habe ich richtig verstanden, von 22 Uhr bis 1 Uhr. Ich werde mir das mal anhören, damit ich mir eine gewisse Vorstellung von dem kriege, was du vorhast, Jörg.
Okay, mach das doch mal.
Einen schönen Abend noch.
Zum Thema Demos-Szene muss man noch sagen, die Mecca-Party wurde ja dann schon öfter erwähnt. Und da muss man dann noch sagen, dass es da nicht etwa nur auf der PC-Plattform Demos gibt, sondern auch noch zum Beispiel auf dem C64, sehr klassiker. Auf Amiga gibt es da nach wie vor Demos, aber auch zum Beispiel auf sehr exotischem Plattform, wo man sowas nicht vermuten würde, wie zum Beispiel auf der Dreamcast-Konsole.
Oder PlayStation, Gameboy, gibt es alles.
Ach.
Die Dreamcast-Konsole wurde auf dieser Mecca jetzt in diesem Jahr auch eine Demo gemacht, und die war sogar sehr gut und hat auch gewonnen da.
Das finde ich ja jetzt klasse. Wo gibt es sowas? Auch bei dir auf der Seite.
Nee, die gibt es nicht bei mir auf der Seite. Also ich bin auch nicht sicher, ob es die jetzt auf einem FDP-Server gibt.
Ja, es wird sich auch schwierig gestalten, das selber irgendwie sich anzugucken zu haben auf der Dreamcast. Denn um das darzustellen, braucht man natürlich auch braucht man natürlich auch erstmal einen CD-Brenner. Und muss dann auch erstmal Dreamcast-kompatible CDs hinkriegen.
Ach Gott.
Also ein lösbares Problem.
Ein lösbares Problem, um nur einzusehen. Du musst kurz mal einen Geräusch machen. Eine Sekunde. Eine Minute nach zwölf. Nee, hatte ich schon gesagt, nur noch eins. Und zwar ist Chaosradio 62, noch eine Stunde reden wir über die Demoszene und haben Musik aus der Demoszene mit. Was hören wir jetzt?
Ja, wir hören jetzt... Kenny Veltri heißt das und der Titel heißt Bleak.
Ausnahmsweise mal eine kürzere Platte als sonst. Chaosradio 62 ist es hier um 5 nach 12. Die Demoszene unserer Thema, und wenn ihr mitreden wollt.
03315, Potsdam 7097110.
Guten Abend, Schemp.
Schemp?
Ich heiße nicht Schemp.
Na ja, aber man schreibt es dann Schemp oder wie?
Nee, da schreibt man auch kein Stück Schemp.
Das wär ein Ding. Warum hast du denn draußen gesagt, dass...
aber mit SCAMP.
Ja, tach.
Ich kann es leider nicht überprüfen, ob ich jetzt wirklich live auf Sendung bin.
Hallo Simon.
Wieso kannst du das nicht überprüfen? Wieso kannst du das nicht überprüfen?
Tja, leider empfangen wir hier in der Rhein-Ebene keinen Fritz.
Oh, wo bist du?
Bingen am Rhein, Arsch der Welt.
Bingen?
Alter Vater.
Simon, versuch mal mit Real Audio. Leider klappt der MP3-Stream nicht. Das hatte ich schon vor einer Weile.
Ne, der braucht schon eine Viertelstunde hin. Deswegen heulen ja auch alle.
Ja, es ist sehr traurig. Also die technischen Probleme liegen leider beim CCC, was den MP3-Stream angeht.
Aber der Real Audio-Stream ist ja auch hin.
Der Real Audio-Stream ist nicht hin, der ist voll, vermute ich mal.
Jaja, irgendwie MP3 geht halt nicht.
Ist halt traurig, aber was machst du denn so, Gimp? Ja, nachdem ich jetzt vorhin leider auf dem Weg hierher über eine Bratwurst gestolpert bin, mich deswegen eine Stunde verspätet habe, hab ich eigentlich so nur zwei Minuten von eurem Programm gehört. Das hat mir allerdings sehr gut gefallen, weil ich hab irgendwie die Wayfinder-Tracks, die man auch den ganzen Tag im Auto hört, wie der mal gehört. Ja, ich hab gehört Wayfinder, ihr habt verbrecherlicherweise die UC erwähnt.
Ja, Entschuldigung, das tut mir sehr leid. Ich hab da im Zusammenhang mit der Testplattenweitruf. Ja, die UC, da wollen wir jetzt gar nicht weiter drauf eingehen.
Die Abkürzung ist benutzt, jetzt wird sie wenigstens mal erklärt.
Ja, das ist die Underground-Conference, aber mehr wird da jetzt nicht drüber gesagt. Das soll ein süßes Geheimnis bleiben.
Ein romantisches, nein, das ist also im Prinzip, kann man sich das so vorstellen, ist auch eine Demoparty, die allerdings etwas geschlossen ist, in dem halt wirklich dann nur die Leute...
Sagen wir klar, Tex, es ist eine invite-only-Party, also nur auf Einladung.
Richtig. Also falls hier vorhin die Uhr hier genannt wurde, dürft euch gerne die Homepage angucken, aber es ist halt wirklich nur für Leute gedacht, die aktiv dort sind. Das hat nichts mit Arroganz zu tun, dass man uns das nicht nachher vorwirft oder von wegen Liebnis, Blas...
Hey, und wenn schon, oder? Ich mein...
Nee.
Ich mein, manchmal möchte man eben unter sich bleiben, ist doch okay.
Genau, das drückt es eigentlich aus. Es ist nur eine Party, wo die Leute wirklich der harte Kern der Szene unter sich sein will.
Genau, wo dann ich hinterher wieder irgendwie was in den Spiegel online steht.
Oder auf Erzherzweil nach.
Am besten niemand erfährt, was davon das überhaupt gibt.
Man hat ja keiner gehört.
Bravo Screen Fun und so ein Kack. Ich mein, Mecca ist nach wie vor eine geniale Party. Ich liebe die Mecca, aber es ist halt wirklich so, da kommen dann halt irgendwelche Leute vorbei und sagen, ey bist du nicht hier Mr. Hacker Man und so. Und das ist halt schon ein bisschen peinlich. Die ganze Demoszene wird natürlich letztendlich kommerzialisiert. Man könnte natürlich Fritz vielleicht auch runterfallen lassen, aber ich denke mal CCC Radio ist okay. Und einerseits bringt es natürlich neue Leute dazu. Andererseits meiner Meinung nach bringt es aber leider zum größten Teil eben Leute, die gar nicht aktiv mitwirken wollen, sondern eigentlich mehr so, als so wie man früher mit seinen Barbiepuppen gespielt hat. Man tut dann halt so, als wäre man dabei. Man sagt ja, ich bin der große Coder und so weiter.
Gruppis nennt man so Leute glaube ich.
Ah Gruppis, ja das stimmt.
Ja das ist so ein Phänomen, das man auch nicht wirklich abwegt.
Nur sagen wir mal, in anderen Szenen sehen die Gruppis dann halt wenigstens gut aus.
Was macht man denn, wenn man sozusagen nicht nur Gruppi ist? Also ich meine, wie gestaltet sich sozusagen die Aktivität in der Szene?
Naja, ich will mal anders anfangen. Es war früher, sagen wir mal so vor, sagen wir mal so 1990 rum. Da war es halt so, dass es relativ schwierig war in die Szene überhaupt erstmal ranzukommen. Es gab halt, ich meine es gab Shido-Net etc. Aber es war auf jeden Fall, es gab auch natürlich Partys auf denen man ging, aber die Hürde war erstmal da. Man musste erstmal sich überwinden dort hinein zu kommen. Heute ist das so, es gibt sich ISC-Channels, die Partys kennt jeder. Teilweise werden sie mit LAN-Partys verwechselt. Und die Leute kreuzen einfach auf, ohne sich zu bemühen. Das hat auch meiner Meinung nach den Nachteil, dass die Leute auch nicht das Gefühl haben, dass sie was erreicht haben, was Besonderes sind, dadurch, dass sie jetzt eben dabei sind, dazugehören. Im Prinzip gibt es eben diese Hürde nicht mehr. Diese Hürde wird immer mehr abgebaut und damit versandet die Szene. Und das finde ich halt persönlich sehr schade.
Und was findest du gut? Was codest du denn? Das würde mich ja sehr interessieren.
Auf MECA haben wir einen, der war auf Wayfinder beteiligt. Der hat die wunderbare Musik gemacht. Wayfinder hast du ja nicht gespielt.
Nee, die habe ich gar nicht dabei. Das war der Happy Hardcore Remix von Stronger.
Aber super geil, die Leute haben dazu getanzt. Wir haben das Ding gar nicht richtig herbekommen, haben die ganze Party durchgecoded. Nur noch so halb am Leben und alles Mögliche in sich hinein geworfen, um irgendwie wach zu bleiben. Wogemerk natürlich keine illegalen Drogen. Kinder, bitte nehmt keine illegalen Drogen.
Warum nicht?
Wir haben am Ende die Partie zu Ende, haben was dann auf dem Big Screen zeigen können. Danke dafür nochmal an die MECA Organizer. Und ich denke, das kam mir nicht ganz gut an. Das haben wir so gecoded. Ansonsten code ich einen Tracker. Weil ich hab ja das Thema Tracker schon gehabt.
Wir sind noch nicht ins Detail gegangen.
Tracker sag ich mir nicht.
Das können wir auch noch abreißen.
Kannst du ja einfach mal erklären aus deiner Perspektive, was ein Tracker macht.
Ja, ein Tracker ist ja so quasi, aber eigentlich Wayfinder ist eigentlich der Profi für. Aber es ist halt ein Musikprogramm, wo das dann bei Wayfinder zählt.
Ja, also Tracker sind Programme, mit denen man Musik machen kann. Das ist im Prinzip so, dass man sich die Klänge irgendwie aussucht, als Samples einlädt. Und dann mit diesen Samples, die in verschiedenen Tonhöhen abspielen kann und mehrere gleichzeitig. Daraus entsteht dann Musik. Das Ganze hat so eine Art Listencharakter, dass man also so eine Abspielliste hat, wo man dann hintereinander einträgt, welche Noten gespielt werden sollen, mit welchem Instrument. Und dann wird das Ganze abgespeichert in einem Format, was sowohl die kompletten Klänge, also die Samples enthält, als auch die Information, was abzuspielen ist. Und das Ganze ist dann relativ klein für eine relativ große Menge an Musik. Also der Länge eines Tracks sind im Prinzip keine Grenzen gesetzt, selbst wenn er nur 80-90 Kilobyte groß ist, kann er trotzdem 10-20 Minuten spielen. Und das ist halt super praktisch für Intros, für Demos, wo halt nicht so viel Platz da ist, dass man jetzt meinetwegen ein 30 Megabyte großes MP3 reinpacken könnte.
Gehört das denn zwingend dann zum Intro dazu, oder kriege ich das auch einzeln? Also im Prinzip ist das doch total klasse, dass ich dann irgendwie auf meinem kleinen Taschenorganizer irgendwie einen riesen Jukebox drauf habe, um einen Trecker da drauf laufen zu lassen.
Es gibt ja auch auf jeder Partie, wie gesagt, diese Music-Compos. Und da wurden halt eben Tracker-Music, also heutzutage ist es meist so, dass eben eine Tracker-Music-Compo gibt und eine MP3-Compo getrennt. Und da können sich natürlich die Stücke dann auch schön runterladen und bei sich abspielen.
Ja, das Coole an den Treckern finde ich, dass sie im Prinzip so eine Mischung sind aus MP3 und MIDI. Was ja eigentlich so die beiden gängigsten Arten und Weisen und Technologien sind, die heute irgendwie Musik machen ermöglicht. Bloß MIDI war halt schon immer mehr so das Fernsteuern von Geräten. Und MP3 war halt einfach nur so der fertige Klang, der aber sehr viel Speicherplatz einnahm.
Wobei man dazu sagen kann...
Und Trecker ist ja im Prinzip eine Mischung aus beiden. Du hast halt sowohl die Komposition irgendwie auf Notenbasis so ähnlich wie MIDI, aber eben auch gleich die Klänge, sozusagen die Synthesizer, auch noch gleich mitten der Datei. Und das ist dann trotzdem alles sehr klein und sehr kompakt und sehr schnell.
Ja, das Weiteren sollte man vielleicht auch erwähnen, dass eben diese Trecker, die damit erstellten Musikstücke, die werden in sogenannten Modulen abgespeichert. Und das ist auch eine schöne Sache, wenn man eine MIDI-Datei zum Beispiel weitergibt, dann klingt die bei irgendjemand ganz anders, wenn er entsprechende Geräte hat, klingt sie ganz scheiße. Diese Module enthalten halt alle benötigten Informationen, um diese Datei auch ohne den Trecker auf anderen Rechnern abzuspielen.
Und zwar genau so, wie der sich das vorgestellt hat.
Genau, es hat halt den Vorteil, es hat halt das Gute von mp3 irgendwie, dass es immer gleich klingt und auch komplexe Klänge hat. Und das Gute von MIDI, dass es einfach kleine Dateien sind.
Also dieser Trecker-Module, da gibt es auch unzählige Formate. Und da kann ich halt zumindest für die Windows-Plattform nur sagen, mit dem ModPlugPlayer, da kann man eigentlich so 99 Prozent, kann man sagen, von diesen Trecker-Modulen auch abspielen.
Ich schreib den URL gleich mal auf.
Da kommt auch noch eine Linkliste.
Bitte, wie heißt er nochmal?
Scamp.
Was programmierst du denn?
Also was ich derzeit, nochmal so, ich bin leider zum einen kommerziell ausgelastet. Ansonsten, wenn ich Zeit habe, organisiere ich ziemlich viel in der Szene. Verschiedene Meetings, kleinere, die auch den jetzt bei euch dort sitzenden Personen verkannt sein dürften. Dann halt diese Undercorn-Konferenz und dann Coden halt. Zum einen arbeite ich derzeit an einem Nachfolger von einem relativ bekannten DOS-Tracker, den es Anfang der 90er mal gab, dem X-Tracker. Da wird es demnächst was zu sehen geben. Das kann ich sogar die URL nennen, das ist nämlich nicht so underground. Das ist www.xtracker32.org. Ist vorgemerkt, das heißt, da wird nichts kosten. Das ist auch bei den meisten Trackern, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen, die geringe Scherbergebühren dauf. Das läuft also alles wirklich von Leuten, die das eben zum Spaß machen. Ansonsten würde ich mich jetzt nicht als Coder-God so was hinstellen.
Das machen die Leute nicht. Was unterscheidet die einzelnen Trackern aus deiner Perspektive? Was mich ein bisschen wundert, ist, dass sich so viele unterschiedliche Formate gehalten haben. Dass es nicht frühzeitig dazu gekommen ist, dass so ein Überfliegerformat...
Die hauptsächlichen Unterschiede liegen eigentlich im Interface. Es gibt viele Leute, die kommen mit der einen Sorte Interface, die völlig ohne Maus auskommt. Im Prinzip fast Programmiercharakter hat, von der Art der Arbeit, wie man da rangeht. Die kommen damit halt nicht klar. Es gibt Leute, die kommen damit nicht klar, dass sie ständig zwischen Keyboard und Maus wechseln und halt klicken können und hier ein Knopf und da ein Knopf. Da gibt es halt solche und so eine. Alle haben irgendwo ihre Vorteile und alle haben irgendwo ihre Anhängerschaft. Und das ist halt nicht so, dass ich jetzt einen großartig durchgesetzt hätte. Es gab mal vor einer Weile eine Situation, als es nur einen Tracker gab, den Fast Tracker, der halt wirklich die guten Features hatte und der wirklich einfach durch Können überzeugt hat. Da gab es dann ein großes Übergewicht. Aber als dann die anderen Leute auch nachgezogen sind, dann hat sich das auch wieder einigermaßen eingependelt. Und jetzt ist es halt wieder einer unter vielen.
Also formatmäßig muss man aber heutzutage sagen, es gibt viele Formate, aber eigentlich sind zwei Formate hauptsächlich vertreten heutzutage. Das Format vom Fast Tracker, das XM Format und das Format vom Impuls Tracker, das ist IT Format. Das sind eigentlich so die beiden Hauptformate heutzutage.
Man sollte vielleicht was dazu sagen, weil die russische Frage, glaube ich, mehr um die Format ging als über die Tracker. Das Ganze muss man sehen, dass diese Formate alle historisch gewachsen sind. Diese Tracker Szene hat angefangen auf dem Amiga. Es gab damals sogar in der Anfangszeit der Technomusik gab es einige Songs, die wirklich auf so einem Tracker auf einem Amiga geschrieben wurden. Und da war eben das Mod oder manche Leute sagen auch Mod-Format. Das bekannteste, das hat aber Begrenzung. Es konnte nur 8-Bit-Samples, es konnte nur maximal 4-Channels. Das wurde dann später haben, dass dann andere Tracker-Programmierer ein bisschen aufgebohrt. Das Format, das dann 8-Channels ging. Aber es war generell eben, sagen wir mal, auf dem kleinen Heimcomputer ausgelegt von den Möglichkeiten. Und so ist dann in der Zeit, sind dann eben neue Formate entstanden. Und ja, und wir haben jetzt auch eben schon, ich weiß nicht, ob wir einen da ganz richtig bemerkt haben. Im Moment ist eigentlich das Wichtigste, ist der Fast Tracker 2 mit seinem XM-Format. Das ist allerdings halt ein DOS-Tracker. Das ist halt, sagen wir mal so, für viele Leute nicht mehr ganz zeitgemäß. Und halt der Impuls-Tracker, der halt auch ein DOS-Tracker ist. Und dann gibt es halt in letzter Zeit kommen halt vermehrt...
Mit DOS-Tracker meinst du, dass er nur unter DOS läuft?
Richtig, laufen halt im DOS-Fenster mit ein bisschen Glück. Und mittlerweile gibt es halt auch Tracker für Windows. Da gibt es zum Beispiel den MadTracker 2, der wird von einigen Leuten ganz gerne benutzt. Es gibt den Modplug-Tracker, der eine Menge von verschiedenen Formaten auch bearbeiten kann. Diese Windows-Tracker sind aber eigentlich unter den Hardcore-Leuten nicht besonders beliebt. Also das ist also schon so, dass die meisten Leute, die in der Szene aktiv sind und mit ihrer Musik Erfolg haben, möchte ich sagen, denke ich eher auf Zeug wie Impulse-Track oder DOS setzen, da einfach Windows auch noch schon seine Nachteile hat im Bereich von Trackern. Also zum einen das Abzeugnis zu nennen, die Latenz, das heißt die Zeit, die es braucht, bis man eine Taste gedrückt hat und entsprechend dann auch die Note gespielt wird. Die ist bei den meisten Windows-Trackern deutlich höher als unter DOS, wo halt die Hardware noch direkt programmiert wurde. Und also wir hatten generell eine gute, ich weiß nicht, ich wollte es glaube ich erwähnen, ich habe es zumindest erwähnt, hat schon Wafine, da ist ein Rede schon abgelassen. Eine gute Website von einem wirklich coolen Typen, der das schon seit Jahren macht zum Grundumzimmer Tracker und auch Player für Tracker-Musik ist www.matzsound.com der man macht das schon seit Jahren. Der ist zwar in der Kernszene, Demoscene nicht so aktiv, aber er gehört einer zu den Leuten, die halt mehr so am Rand wirklich auch selbstlos für die Szene arbeiten.
Vor allem kann man auf der Seite, die er gerade erwähnt hat, kann man jede Menge Tracker und Player runterladen. Alles kostenlos.
Das ist doch wunderbar. Scamp, an dieser Stelle danke für deinen Anruf. Wir haben noch ein paar in der Leitung.
Ok, folgende Frage. Kann ich am Telefon weiter mithören, weil Stream gibt es ja leider nicht.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Kannst du den Audio-Stream nicht erreichen?
Ich kann dich natürlich jetzt hier in die Warteschleife hängen, aber das kostet ein Schweine Geld.
Englisch rein.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal. Ich hab das noch nie gemacht. Matthias, ich stell ihn dir mal raus. Kann er dann ein Programm hören, wenn er nach draußen in der Warteschleife hängt? Es hört sich gut an. Viel Glück, Scamp. Ich schäme mich auf.
Ich bleib dran. Simon, grüßt mir die Leute auf dem Channel. Es tut mir persönlich sehr leid, dass das mit dem Stream nicht so klappt. Das hätte ich mir leider ein bisschen besser vorgestellt.
Was ist denn der Dereal-Audio-Stream von Fritz? Der läuft doch, oder nicht?
Theoretisch läuft der. Ich wüsste nicht, warum nicht. Es gibt lediglich nicht den MP3-Stream.
Ja, der MP3-Stream war auch das, was eigentlich so erster Linie erhofft wurde.
Ja, natürlich erhofft. Ja, den gibt es dann eben nicht. Das muss ich jetzt aber dazu sagen, weil das klingt ja echt ein bisschen...
Wir werden ihn ja auch nicht herbeirehen.
Es ist halt einfach, das Internet ist ausgefallen.
Genau, das Internet ist kaputt.
Das Internet halt gerade nicht funktioniert.
Ja, hier ist das Chaosradio über 62 übrigens und wir reden über die Demoszene und über den MP3-Stream, den ich gehe. Guten Abend, Oskar, bist du noch dran? Wir müssen lange noch warten. Entschuldigung.
Grüß dich.
Folgende Frage. Also vorhin hat jemand angerufen, das wollte ich kurz erzählen. Der hat erzählt, dass unter UNOSME seine Demo nicht läuft. Und das liegt daran, dass verschiedene Firmen halt zu faul waren, extra noch mal Treiber dafür rauszubringen. Ich hatte das Problem auch mit meiner Voodoo 3, dass halt verschiedene Sachen, dass man sie nicht angucken konnte.
Also Voodoo ist noch wieder so ein Grafikkarte-mäßiges Thema für sich. Ich kann zwar nicht so viel zu sagen, aber generell Voodoo-Karten für Demos ist nicht unbedingt ideal.
Nee, aber...
Was wäre dann ideal?
Ideal ist eine Standard-mäßig Karte mit NVIDIA Chatsets.
Ja, NVIDIA oder jetzt Kyro 2, der an sich nicht schlecht ist. Und dann noch mal eine Frage.
Haben wir einen Arzt hier?
Das hat sich ja doch nicht mehr so angeregt. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht. Ja, was war das denn gerade?
Hast du die Rolls-Band-Taste gedrückt?
Ich war irgendwie weg.
Nein, du warst weg.
Ich war weg?
Ja, also zumindest bei uns auch.
Was war denn jetzt noch?
Ich hab dir das auch nicht gesagt. Das Internet ist kaputt. Oskar, stell deine Frage einfach nochmal. Bei uns ist nichts angekommen.
Ja, was empfiehlt ihr, wenn man mit Programmieren anfangen möchte? Ich hab von verschiedenen Leuten gehört, C++, aber gibt's von euch irgendwie einen T-Person?
Na, was interessiert dich denn am meisten?
Ich hab jetzt angefangen, ich kann unter HTML programmieren, was eigentlich keine richtige Programmiersprache ist. Und mach so eine ganze Menge mit Webdesign, aber wollt jetzt halt sozusagen eine richtige Programmiersprache.
Also wenn dich generell Programmiersprachen an sich interessieren und dir sowohl was Abstraktes zum Beispiel mit Websachen machen möchtest und irgendwie so die grundlegenden Eigenschaften von objektorientierter Programmierung erlernen willst, dann bist du sicherlich mit Java nicht schlecht bedient. Weil das gibt es irgendwie überall, das läuft überall. Da brauchst du dir über Plattformen und Produkte nicht viel Gedanken machen. Du hast eine große Auswahl. Als Programmiersprache lässt sie im Detail betrachtet sicherlich noch einiges zu wünschen übrig, aber sie ist auf jeden Fall weniger strafend als irgendwie C++.
Obwohl sie aber auch eine ähnliche Struktur hat.
Ja, aber doch dann eher eine Weiterentwicklung von C ist, als jetzt mit einer Verwandtschaft zu C++.
Zum Thema Java lässt sich noch sagen, es gibt Demos, die in Java programmiert wurden und die sind auch gar nicht schlecht. Es sind nicht allzu viele, aber es gibt einige sehr gute Demos, die in Java gemacht wurden.
Also wenn du jetzt Java lernst und möchtest gerne Demos programmieren, dann ist das kein Hindernis.
Obwohl, wenn du auch Performance ausbist, ist natürlich Java nicht das Ding. Aber wenn es ums Programmieren lernen geht, dann ist das irgendwie keine schlechte Sache. Genau, überhaupt erst mal zu schneiden, was es bedeutet.
Zum Seid Neuerem kann ich dazu nur sagen, es gibt auch Demos, die mit der Flash-Technologie arbeiten. Das gibt es auch schon.
Ja, aber das ist eine andere Art der Programmierung.
Viel Spaß beim Flash-Lernen. So und vor Nachrichten nehmen wir noch Sven dazu. Hallo Sven.
Sven?
Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Sorge, dass ich das einfach hier falsch bediene, wenn da keiner mehr dran ist. Aber der musste lange warten. Also da kann ich verstehen, dass er möglicherweise aufgelegt hat.
Ja, außer wir jetzt vielleicht erst mal wieder ein bisschen Musik spielen, oder?
Ja, das sollten wir vielleicht wirklich tun. Was redest du da hinten im Hintergrund, Talunil, ohne Mikrofon? Du weißt, dass man ohne Mikrofon im Radio nichts sagt, oder? Wenn... Halb eins.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter trocken heute Nacht bei 17 bis 14 Grad morgen, dann nicht mehr trocken, nämlich nachts Schauer und Gewitter bei bis zu 26 Grad. Die Meldung mit Matthias Karcov.
US-Präsident Bush will das hier nehmen. Bei dem nächsten Jahr 329 Milliarden Dollar.
Moment, du sollst mich nicht nacheffen, ja? Die Meldung mit Matthias Karcov.
US-Präsident Bush will im nächsten Jahr 329 Milliarden Dollar für die Verteidigung ausgeben. Die Regierung beantragte beim Kongress über 18 Milliarden Dollar mehr als ursprünglich geplant. Die Herkunft von zwei Millionen Mark auf ein Konto der CDU-nahen Schweizer Norfolk-Stiftung ist offenbar aufgeklärt. Der ehemalige CDU-Finanzberater Weihrauch soll das Geld an einen Mitarbeiter der Schweizer UBS-Bankenbau übergeben haben, berichtet die Bildzeitung. Der Bankangestellte sei auch bereit, vor dem Spenden-Untersuchungsausschuss auszusagen. Bundeskanzler Schulter hat sich grundsätzlich für eine Beteiligung der Bundeswehr in einem NATO-Einsatz in Mazedonien ausgesprochen. Deutschland werde sich seinen internationalen Verpflichtungen nicht entziehen können, sagte er in einem Interview. Wegen der Ermordung eines Obdachlosen hat das Landgericht Schwerin zwei junge Männer zu lebenslanger Haft beziehungsweise sechseinhalb Jahren Jugendhaft verurteilt. Die Angeklagten hatten den zwar 50-jährigen Mann im vergangenen Sommer in Wismar so schwer misshandelt, dass er wenig später starb. Frankreich hat die Wehrpflicht abgeschafft. Der Erfolg bei der Umwandlung der Streitkräfte in einer Berufsarmee habe diesen Schritt ein Jahr früher als geplant ermöglicht, erklärte Präsident Chirac.
Vielen Dank Matthias. Zwei Minuten und halb eins.
KFM, das ist die Sendung, die du hören musst. Denn du weißt, ohne die Sendung, da hast du Fuß. Jeden Samstag von sechs bis zehn, da kannst du auch hingehen, unter den Linden, da sind wir zu finden. Die Samstag-Morgenshow mit Ken Jepsen.
Von sechs bis zehn auf Fritz.
Import von AyoBoxD.
Und gesendet von...
Hier ist das Chaos Radio 62 auf Fritz. Wir reden über die Demoszene und Musik kommt hier gerade wieder aus der Demoszene, denn nämlich Wavefinder ist es, Sebastian ist Wavefinder und bei uns im Studio. Kann ich die nicht kaufen?
Nee, die gibt's aber im Internet runterzuladen, die ganzen Stücke. Der URL, der steht nachher auch bei Fritz auf der Homepage.
Als was? Als MP3s?
Als MP3s, ja.
Als Waves. Damit man's direkt brennen kann.
Ist das das, was da auf dieser CD da ist? Das es gerade in meinem Computer entholtet wird?
Das ist ein exaktes Dupliktat.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer und das ist Pick-Pen. Hallo. Hallo, Nico. Über dich ist ja schon viel geredet worden. Reden wir mal mit dir. Tach.
Hallo. Du bist ein richtiger Demokoder, ne?
Ich bin ein richtiger Demokoder.
Kannst du mal den Telefonhörer an dein Ohr nehmen?
Ich bin...
Ach echt? Du hast Echo, du klingst wie...
Hast du Radio an?
Ne, ne, Radio ist nebenan, Tür ist zu.
Naja, müssen wir mit leben.
Klingt mystisch. Also du codest irgendwie Demos komplett selber, richtig?
Ich code vier Kilobyte-Intros, ja. Vorwiegend und komplett selber. Das muss ich auch gleich mal klarstellen, was vorhin gesagt wurde, als ob ich hier ein Supergenie wäre. Dem ist nicht so, ich programmiere zwar, aber dass ich halt Grafik und Musik, Musik ist auch schon wieder übertrieben, was ich dann selber mache, liegt wirklich notnachterfinderisch. Der Demoszene fehlen neue fähige Leute. Gerade durch diesen Effekt, was Stainscamp angesprochen hat, durch die Verkommerzialisierung der Demoszene halt wirklich ziemlich viele möchte gerne einen Tag fliegen, eintreten und nur um dabei gewesen zu sein.
Wie sieht die Verkommerzialisierung der Demoszene aus? Also wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Da kommt dann irgendwie ein Spielehersteller und sagt, schreib mir mal ein schönes Demo und dafür kriegst du Geld oder wie?
Na eher ein schönes Spiel dann.
Achso.
Also die Leute arbeiten jetzt in zunehmendem Maße für Spiele, Software, Firmen.
Und diese Partys, die angesprochen wurden, zum Beispiel im Mecker-Symposium, also wenn man da jetzt hört, dass da 1500 Leute zum Beispiel sich treffen, ist natürlich klar, dass da eine riesengroße Informationsmaschine vorher gelaufen ist, dass auch wirklich 1500 Leute darüber informiert sind und wenn sie sich anschließend hinzugehen. Und da kommt man natürlich auch nicht drum um, dass verschiedene Clans, die schon angesprochen wurden, das lesen und hören, lauter Rechner ganz viele Leute, tolles Netzwerk und gehen wir hin.
Das heißt, da ist das Mecker-Symposium, ich lese in der Zeitung, da sind 1500 Demoleute und wie viele waren es wirklich?
Also die Mecker-Symposium ist schon eine Ausnahme, da sind wirklich sehr viele Demos hier. Das ist wirklich auch eine richtige Demoparty, wie es sein soll. Also nicht viele Gamer-Spieler eben.
Da wird so ein bisschen drauf geschielte, dass die Spieler nicht überhand nehmen.
Die Party hat eben wirklich noch nicht den Charakter einer LAN-Party, ist keine LAN-Party.
Also da muss ich groß zu sagen, dass die Symposium wirklich mit positiveren Beispielen von allen anderen. Es gibt auch schon Partys, die sterben.
Also insbesondere für die Größe dieser Party ist die wirklich noch sehr gut. Weil es gibt wirklich negative Beispiele, da könnte ich jetzt die The Gathering in Norwegen erwähnen oder auch The Party in Dänemark oder die Assembly in Finnland. Das sind alles Großpartys mit mehr als 3000 Besuchern. Aber da sind wirklich fast nur noch Gamer.
Da gibt es dann zwar immer noch Demo-Competitions und Musik und so, aber da gucken dann vielleicht 100 Leute zu und die anderen 3000 stehen dann davor beim Counter-Strike Turnier.
Aber ich kann eigentlich nicht glauben, dass der Mangel an Nachwuchs darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass Leute Spiele schreiben. Also es ist doch eine ganz andere Motivation oder nicht?
Im Prinzip, ja, also es geht vielen Leuten darum einfach rauszubringen was sie können. Einfach zu zeigen hier so und das auch an den Mann zu bringen und auch ein großes Publikum zu haben.
Die Spiel-Szene ist, Entschuldigung. Diese Spielefirmen, also Firmen die halt ihr Geld verdienen, normal irgendwie wie eine Firma das macht, irgendwie indem sie halt Spiele verkaufen, das ist ja auch ein super großer Markt und da finden viele Leute Platz und sicherlich, also ganz offensichtlich ist es so, dass in diesen Companies natürlich sehr viele wirklich exquisite Grafiker sind und Leute auch Sound machen, die halt auch gut programmieren können. Das ist ja klar, irgendwie das findet man ja in allen Szenen. Aber es dürfte doch eher dabei helfen, dass Leute das überhaupt tun. Ich meine, dadurch werden es ja doch eher mehr, wenn es auch noch die Möglichkeit gibt, mit dem was einem Spaß macht Geld zu verdienen.
Na der Vordergrund der Demos stehen steht ja eigentlich nicht das Geldverdienen. Dabei ist sich ja der Hund selbst entspannt. Das ist ja das Problem an der Sache. Das Geldverdienen ist ja dann bei den Partyorganisern zum Beispiel wieder dann da drin, sondern dass sie dann halt lieber viele Zeit ruhige Gamer da sitzen haben, als ein paar Demos sehen. Können ja nicht als ein böser Vorwurf klingen. Aber ursprünglich war halt wirklich der Kitzel an der Sache, dass man wirklich das Gefühl hat, man ist was Besonderes. Dass der Leute um den Rechner rumstanden und den Mut nicht mal zubekommen haben. Mein Gott, was kann dieser Kasten, der sonst gerade mal irgendwie wird, einbeherrscht oder so.
Und im Endeffekt dann natürlich auch, was kann dieser Typ, der das gemacht hat?
Und heute ist das alles schon so großzeitig angelegt und bekannt. Und dass wirklich, ich sag jetzt mal, jeder Zweite, der sie kann und sich ein bisschen mit irgendwelchen Dokumentationen auseinandersetzt, halt wirklich mal eben irgendwas zusammenklatscht. Und dann sofort natürlich denkt, von wegen ist ja einfach. Und naja, Partys und Geld verdienen kann man auch mit. Und dann rutscht das immer sofort wieder in den Hintergrund, die Demos sehen.
Also ich wäre in deiner Stelle nicht so pessimistisch dabei. Man kann ja auch was Gutes abgewinnen.
In dem Zusammenhang muss ich eigentlich mal dazu sagen, dass dieser Zeitraum in der Mitte eine gute, also eine wirklich qualitätsmäßig gute Demo entsteht. Das sind schon mindestens mehrere Wochen, eigentlich meistens mehrere Monate. Und das war früher so unter DOS-Zeiten, als noch meistens in Assembler programmiert wurde, gecodet, Coding heißt das halt im Szenenjargon. Früher hat das halt eigentlich fast generell mal viele Monate gedauert, bis eine gute Demo zusammengeschustert wurde. Und auch jetzt unter Windows, wo man ja bestimmte Hilfen hat, halt vom Betriebssystem her, dauert es trotzdem immer noch mindestens mehrere Wochen, bis dann wirklich was zusammenkommt, was man zeigen kann.
Solange halt bei dem Thema zu bleiben, das ist dann auch eine Sache der Ausdauer. Und wenn man sich da nicht wirklich der Szene zugehörig fühlt, wird das dann schnell, weil man halt auch nicht so superschnell zu tollen Ergebnissen kommt vielleicht, wird es dann für viele Leute denke ich mal auch wieder so, dass sie sagen, na gut, ich hab's probiert und hat nicht geklappt. Und dann lasse ich das jetzt mal und spiele halt wieder. So kann man sich das vielleicht vorstellen.
Du machst Intros, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Im Wesentlichen oder?
Man gelts früher Herz und Seele dabei und heute nur noch mit dem Herzen und die Seele. Gibt beim Chef nur noch Intro, ja.
In was programmierst du diese Demo?
Winl Assembler.
Auf Winl dann, also unter DOS?
Winl Assembler, nee, ist schon unter Winl, das ist richtig. Sie sind unter Winl lauffähig, benutzen nur 3D-Beschleunigung, Musik und alle Drum und Dran, also die sind schon ansehend, mag man wahrscheinlich nicht glauben, aber dem ist wirklich so.
Auf welcher Ebene machst du die 3D-Beschleunigung mit OpenGL?
Also läuft alles auf Maschinensprachen-Ebene, sonst bleibt er natürlich nicht so klein.
Und benutzt dann natürlich auch die von Windows vorhergebenden Schnittstellen, also OpenGL zum Beispiel oder DirekTown.
Kannst du irgendwie mit deinen Worten mal beschreiben, was eigentlich wie dein Programm aussieht? Also ich meine, wir sind ja jetzt beim Radio, aber irgendwie, wie würdest du beschreiben, wie das aussieht, was dein Programm macht? Ja, also was seh ich?
Also es ist schon wirklich so, dass man halt Musik hört und gleichzeitig, meinetwegen jetzt durch eine generierte 3D-Welt mit Objekten fliegt. Da gibt's ja schon Beispiele von einer Gruppe, die heißt Freestyle zum Beispiel, die machen das in Perfektion. Also da sieht man wirklich wunderschöne anzusehende Objekte, hört unglaublich gute Musik für die Größe und ist dann halt quasi nur so zum Zurücklegen und betrachten also wie 64 Kilobyte quasi.
Was für Objekte fliegen da so durch die Gegend?
Also der schönste Ausdruck, den ich dafür kenne, ist das Technokartoffeln. Das ist eine der häufigsten Objektformen in Intros. Das sind mehr oder weniger runde Gebilde, die so ein bisschen wabern und schön texturiert sind, schön bunt und...
Nein, da ist man aber nur da hinaus.
Ja, aber es gibt immer noch eine Menge. Und ich fand den Ausdruck einfach so klasse.
Die gab es auch lange Zeit auf CD-Carbon ohne Ende.
Ja und jetzt ist halt häufig so, dass, also das war schon immer so, dass aus einem industriellen Umfeld viele Objekte kommen, also Zahnräder und Greifarme und so eine Geschichten. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann halt mehr abstrakte Sachen. Mit Sternen und Würfel gab es früher natürlich eine ganze Menge.
Also das hat Windows jetzt noch als Bildschirmschoner, ne?
Ja, aber selbst diesen Windows Bildschirmschoner, den hat man schon vor zehn Jahren auf dem C64 noch besser und schneller hinbekommen. Ja, wollte ich das mal gesagt haben. Das ist der Sport.
Dann herzlichen Dank für deinen Anruf. Lange geht sie ja nicht mehr. Ein paar Minuten haben wir noch. Wollen wir mal ins Telefon gehen? Sag mal eine Zahl zwischen zwei und fünf, Tim.
Zwischen zwei und fünf und drei.
Ja gut, die blinkt auch. Hallo, ist Chaosradio.
Ja, Scamp hier. Nochmal.
Ja, schon wieder mal.
Glück, weil das gerade mein Lieblingsthema ist, über das du da sprichst.
Welches war das nun?
Wie es aussieht?
Die Verkommerzierung der Demos sehen.
Ja, dann machst du mal ein veritables Schlusswort. Wir gehen nämlich gleich nach Hause.
Oh, das ist ja schön.
Ja, dann bin ich jetzt schon so im Untergrund aktiv. Auf Sendung.
Du bist auf Sendung, ja. Das Agitationsgebiet ist deins jetzt.
Also, ich darf ganz kurz noch mal erwähnen, da ja vorhin, obwohl ich es ganz deutlich gesagt hab, wieder vom Tisch geweckt hab, der V-Audio-Team ist seit einer Stunde platt und die Leute sind alle ganz taurig. Also, ich richte mal Grüße an die armen Leute aus oder so.
Also, richtig platt?
Ich meine, das ist eigentlich voll egal Quatsch, dass du in Grüße ausrät, weil du sollst dich eh nicht hören, aber ich kann die dann ja ausrichten. Ja, es ist richtig platt seit einer Stunde. Es hat plötzlich abgebrochen für alle Leute. Und sowohl jetzt Leute, die auf dem Chaosradio-Channel, auf IRCCCC.de, als auch Leute im ALS-Cnet, die halt dann die Szene halt, Szenegäer et cetera, die sind alle ganz taurig. Und wir haben aber gerade, einer hat es jetzt geschafft, sein Radio irgendwie an wie ein Audios-Team anzuschließen. Jetzt, gerade im Anblick, als ich durchgekommen bin zu euch, lief dann das Team, toll, toll, toll, egal. Was ich sagen wollte, ich habe da das Ende, weil ich ihn neu anrufen musste, nicht mehr mitbekommen, von dem, was Pigman sagte. Aber ich möchte mal, kurz so, und Schlusswort heute, Problem-Kommerz-Hilfe in der Demos-Szene. Ist glaube ich weniger, dass jetzt irgendwelche Games-Leute Games coden, denn viele Leute, die jetzt in der Game-Produktions-Szene aktiv sind, coden trotzdem noch Demos. Also das Beispiel, das bekannteste Beispiel ist Chaos von Fabrausch. Aber was das eigentliche Problem ist, muss ich jetzt so vorstellen, als wir noch klein waren und jung und dynamisch und so noch in Schule waren, da war es so, dass wir Computerspacken eigentlich, der größte Teil von uns eigentlich nicht akzeptiert wurde.
Muss man vielleicht mal kurz noch dazu sagen, das typische Durchschnittsalter des Cenas liegt irgendwo so um die 20. Die unter 20 sind ein bisschen drüber, aber auf jeden Fall so im Durchschnitt vielleicht so um die 20 Jahre.
Vielleicht hast du das nur gerade gemittelt aus deinem Alter, das zählt nicht.
Ich bin fast 35, bin ich da wirklich eine Ausnahme?
Ich bin auch schon ein alter Sack. Was ich sagen wollte, es war jedenfalls so, dass früher die Leute, die am Computer aktiv waren, gesellschaftlich ausgeschlossen waren. Die anderen Leute haben mit Fussballen gespielt, sich über Frauen unterhalten und blabla, was auch immer alles. Und diese Leute, die in dieser Szene aktiv waren, eben nicht. Die wurden eigentlich normalerweise gesellschaftlich ausgeschlossen, verhöhnt, was auch immer. Die haben sich dann eben zusammengerottet und haben eben diese Szene sich aufgebaut, in der die Leute sich untereinander respektiert haben und geholfen haben, egal wie sie aussehen, egal wie sie rumlaufen, was für ein Kleidersiegeschmack sie haben, wo die Leute wirklich nach Wurzeln sind, wie sie sich verurteilt wurden, wie sie sich verhalten haben und was sie produziert haben. Und das wurde halt eine sehr, sehr enge Bindung, die auch vielen Leuten, also gerade das kennt man ja auch, die Leute vom CCC soll das auch wissen, eben diese Nerds, was man ja auch so ist, wie entsprechend eben schlecht behandelt wurden. Man hat sich eben seine eigene Welt geschaffen, in der man eben aufgehen konnte. Und für viele Leute, muss man sagen, viele Leute hat das eben über Selbstmordphasen etc. hinweg geholfen. Und es ist schon eine feste Familie.
Heute ist es nicht mehr nötig, ne?
Nee, das ist geil. Heute ist es so, ich will dazu eine kleine langweilige Anekdote erzählen. Ich bin letztens irgendwann von einer Polizeikontrolle gekommen, nach einer Demo-Party. Das Auto war total versifft, voll mit Computer, irgendwelchen Schwachsinn, man will immer alles mögliche mitschleppen dahin. Und da meinte so der nette Herr Polizist zu mir, ja, das was ja ziemlich verdächtig aussieht, falls ich da alles hinten drin hätte, was ich denn treiben würde. Und dann meinte ich ja, ich geh mal grad von der Demo-Party, das wär so eine Party, so. Und da hat er gesagt, wisst ihr jetzt, was es ist? Ja, ach ja genau, aber so macht das auch immer. Und fährt dann mit Games hin, und tritt auf da das ganze Wochenende. Und das hat mich so angekotzt, ja. Ich mein, hätte er jetzt gesagt, ja, sie sind Tempo 200 gefahren, ich wär jetzt fast mehr mit das Sieber gewesen.
Jetzt ist es normal unterstrengend.
Man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Leute, die sich früher über einen lustig gemacht haben, einem jetzt die Szene auch noch wegnehmen wollen.
Die ärgern sich natürlich dabei.
Ich kann das nicht so pessimistisch sehen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, das war einfach eine Szene von Leuten, die in ihren intersozialen Kontakten bestimmte Defekte oder Probleme aufwiesen. Das kenn ich auch sehr gut. Das gilt natürlich für alle Hacker. Für alle Nerds ist das einfach so ein klassisches Problem. Von daher hat man diese super kooperative Szene, wie sie auch immer heißen mag, ob das jetzt die Demoscene ist oder Open Source oder wo auch immer sich irgendwie diese Teilgruppen von diesen Nerds finden. Weil Nerds sind halt einfach nett. Nerds sind einfach total nette Menschen. Weitgehend so. Und es ist eigentlich auch eine sehr coole Szene. Sie sind manchmal ein bisschen ruppig irgendwie. Sie sprechen eckig. Sie tun auch manchmal Dinge in einer bestimmten Intensität, was den meisten Leuten ein bisschen merkwürdig vorkommt. Aber keiner kann sich irgendwie beschweren, dass Nerds nicht hilfsbereite Menschen wären, sondern die sich gerade mit einem religiösen Enthusiasmus eigentlich auf alles stürzen und irgendwie da ihre Selbstfindung finden. Das ist natürlich in der Ausprägung Demoszene ganz genauso. Aber was ich sagen wollte, warum es eben nicht pessimistisch zu betrachten ist, das hat einfach viele Leute dann auch angezogen. Also eigentlich sind es die Bestätigungen dafür, dass diese Szene eben auch diesen Wert tatsächlich gehabt hat. Und es ist selbstverständlich, dass in dem Moment, wo sie eine gewisse Qualität aufweist, viele Leute ranziegt. Die das dann natürlich nicht mehr so richtig verstehen und die Geschichte nicht kennen und lalala. Und auch selber ganz eigene Zwänge und andere Probleme haben, sich von daher da auf andere Sachen machen, aber trotzdem dort andocken und sich da wohlfühlen.
Ich meine, ich fände euch das mal so. Ich stell dir vor, du bist irgendwie ein Rocker mit deinem tollen Biker Club und ihr habt ein Rocker Clubheim und ihr macht alles, was Rocker machen, sich halt wie eine Würste hinter die Ohren stecken und lauter solche Sachen. Und ihr seid kräftig am Rumrocken und dann macht ihr irgendwann, irgendwann ist dann Tag der offenen Tür und ihr seid irgendwie 30 Rocker und auf einmal kommen 100 Blümchenfans rein und tanzen da alle irgendwie sich in euren Füßen rum. Das ist zwar, klar kannste sagen, oh toll, wir Rocker sind populär, aber trotzdem hast du das Problem, du kannst dann eben nicht mehr unter, man ist nicht mehr unter sich. Und ein weiterer Punkt ist, diese Szene besteht ganz maßgeblich aus Geben und Nehmen. Das ist einfach wirklich so, du hängst dann rum und du hast irgendwann, der ist jetzt Pixel, der macht Grafiken und du bist gerade am Democode und hast keine Grafiken für was, ey, machen wir mal eine Grafik. Oder hier Wayfinder, ich brauch mal einen Track für irgendein Demo. Solche Sachen, so läuft das ab. Aber es gibt halt, jeder kann was und gibt was. Aber wenn dann eben Leute dabei kommen, die eben nichts geben können, weil sie eben nichts können, sondern nur nehmen, dann kann das System nicht funktionieren und dann geht das System kaputt auf Dauer.
Ich meine, ich sehe es auch nicht spezifisch, wir werden überleben, wir haben schon, ich meine, es gibt auch keine einzige Szene auf diesem Planeten, die es irgendwie schafft, länger als 20 Jahre irgendwie total super geil und voll knuffig und für alle Beteiligten das Größte zu sein, verstehst du? Irgendwann ist die Luft raus und dann pufft das eben in was Neues rein. Aber das muss ja nicht genau so heißen, aber das sind dann im Prinzip die gleichen Leute, die dann halt Underground-Konferenzen machen, weil sie feststellen, wir müssen mal irgendwie mal unter uns sein und mal ein bisschen nachdenken, was wir eigentlich wollen so. Und dann vielleicht so ein neues Boot, ein kleines Firmware-Update einspielen und dann irgendwie zack die nächste Marschrichtung verfolgen. Und dann geht es halt immer weiter.
Man geht halt weiter in den Untergrund und versucht halt wieder Sachen zu finden, die man machen kann, die andere Leute wieder nicht als amüsant empfinden würden oder nicht als begehrend werden.
Wir müssen jetzt mal Feierabend machen hier. Ich weiß ja, das ist schön, ja. Nichts für ungut, dass wir hier drei Stunden gesendet haben.
Hat mich auf jeden Fall unheimlich gefreut, dass du angerufen hast. War auf jeden Fall ein sehr wertvoller Beitrag.
Ja, aber die Idee von dir, dass du da zum CCC bist, das war im Vergleich zu dem, was bisher an Demos in den Berichten gab, war das jetzt wirklich im Vergleich ein sehr ruhiges Niveau.
Und wie wir nur gesagt haben, noch mal der Hinweis, diese Sendung kann man später vom CCC-Server oder auch vom Fritz-Server komplett als MP3 runterladen. Also wer das Pech hatte, die nicht hören zu können, wegen der Probleme mit Real Audio und MP3 Stream, der sollte sich, wenn er die Wand breitet, hat dieses MP3 antun. Er wird da keinen Fehler machen.
Scann, mach's gut.
Ich sag euch alle übrigens auch für die Leute auf Sceniga grüßen, von Talks, Tic, Note, MBW, Kaotik und so weiter und so fort.
Der Grüßer ist der Feind des Hörers. Eine gute Nacht. Das war Chaosradio 62. Die Demoscene war unser Thema. Haben wir noch was vergessen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Gut, dann sagen wir an dieser Stelle einfach Tschüss. Sagt Tschüss. Tschüss, das nächste Chaosradio, also Chaosradio 63 am 1.8. Und hier geht's ab 1 Uhr weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf.
Spritz, ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB, produziert in Babelsberg.
Ich bin schon mal da.